[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu
[Musique]
bonjour chers amis chers ennemis
bonoir bienvenue sur le plateau de tout
le monde en parle l'émission qui
parle avec nous ce soir Michel
ser Vanessa
Paradis Patrick
sit Laurent
Dutch Vincent
payon Jean-Paul
Gautier Tony Marchall Ivan
Attal mélodie Gouin ou Nadia farè ouis
Cécile
Cassel
Booba Nicolas Reay noui
laner le blind test spécial battle Axel
le dauphin contre crise de
multifonction et l'inégalable Laur
[Applaudissements]
BAFF
je vous demande de vous
arrêter ça va mon Lolo laille bord der
a la dernière émission de la saison
mesdames messieurs ce soir mais on se
retrouvera quand même lundi à 20h50 pour
un prime time qui s'appelle opinion
publique alors on parlera du cannabis
faut-il mettre le cannabis en vente
libre le nudisme le nudisme conduit-il à
des déviances sexuelles et il y a-t-il
trop de P dans les médias voilà c'est
opinion publique face au panel non oui
et oui comme ça ça vous évite de
regarder pouvez c'est
[Musique]
bien
voici
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
micheles pass pas la main tout le Mondev
la
main
[Applaudissements]
je vous demande de vous
arrêter c'est trop ça mérite pas ça
c'est trop mais c'est mérité si ah si si
quand même ou ouis si si si si merci
alors alors Michel
zch la deuxième fois c'est pas mérité
Laurent tu es d'accord non non là là
c'est c'est trop non mais là il y en
avait autant pour toi et pour on démarre
sur l'hommage et ça tourne au foutage de
gueule moi je je
stop disons tu sais comme je t'aime toi
c'est bien réciproque tu es bien tu es
bien à des solol parce que
aussiou bin il y a pas grand monde qui
résiste et surtout pas beaucoup de
comicqu ouis pas beaucoup de com de
comiqu qui trouvent grâce à tes yeux il
y en a pas beaucoup ah si pas dans le
livre pas dans le livre dans dans les
vivants
non bien alors Michel donc le fameux
sondage du journal du du dimanche qui
donne le classement des Français
préférés des Français
oui vous a nommé premier comédien
préféré des Français mais c'est
[Applaudissements]
quoi que le le le succès du Journal du
Dimanche est sans doute dû à la miniérie
de de TF1 qui s'appelle l'affaire de
minichi meilleure audience de TF1 en
2003 12,2 millions de téléspectateurs
50 % de par de marché alors ce qui est
intéressant oui
oui il y avait vraiment une osmose
parfaite entre entre vous Michel serro
et le personnage de Gaston Dominici on
vous a dit et je pense qu'on avait
raison on vous a dit vous ne jouez pas
Dominici vous êtes Dominici vous et
c'est la vérité ouais réellement je suis
Dominici oui c'est moi Dominici ou et je
vais passer en jugement bientôt vous
serez quitté Michel non mais ce qui est
vrai c'est que souvent on parle des
méthodes de l'acteur studio où les gens
pour tourner quelqu'un comme Gaston
Dominici vont tuer des Anglais dans voà
ou en tous les cas s'immerger dans la
dans la campagne voir comment on nourrit
les poules et et et vous en fait Michel
vous avez fait appel à à à des souvenirs
personnels vous avez pas fait de
préparation oui mais d'une manière enfin
d'une façon générale quand même je ne
suis pas non plus tu sais j'ai tourné le
le docteur PEO oui tu as jamais mis de
gonzè dans dans ta chaudière non plus
oui oui j'ai pas de chaudière à la
maison j'ai Pasi c'est vrai oui enfin il
y a un tas de chos comme ça je ne suis
pas non plus dans garde à vue j'ai pas
assassiné la petite fille c'est vrai
c'est vrai mais ce que vous dites quand
même et vous avez raison pour être pour
être comédien il faut avoir la mémoire
des autres peut-être bah si oui non mais
je crois que pour jouer la comédie il
faut prendre un parti prix je veux pas
jouer Dominici poo sans avoir à mon avis
là-dessus sinon j'ai rien à dire je me
fais remplacer alors voilà il y a
beaucoup de de réflexion de cette
qualité dans un livre que Michel Serot
publie chez ha édition qui s'appelle les
pieds dans le plat je l'ai lu tu l'as lu
alors c'est un journal tenu de façon un
petit peu irrégulière au irrégulière
parce qu'on a pas toujours l'occasion de
de oui de par des événements quoi oui
d'ailleurs vous pouvez on peut changer
si on veut changer les dates pour les
réflexions on n pas à 8 jours près
quoioua ouais alors on va rester dans le
métier d'acteur si tu veux avec si vous
voulez pardon avec un acteur qui
s'appelle Fabrice Lucini ah c'est un ami
à moi oui vous dites Fabrice Lucini
m'agace ce qui vous agace chez Fabrice
Lucini c'est qu'il a déclaré reprendre
pour la première fois le rôle de kn de
Louis Jouvet comme s'il était un petit
peu l'héritier de de de Jouvet et de son
talent alors que vous vous l'avez joué
tr fois à la Porte Saint-Martin oui TR
ou 400 fois ou ou donc ça vous choque un
peu quand non mais c'est parce que il
moi je l'aime beaucoup il a beaucoup de
talent mais contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait croire il a peut-être pas assez
de mémoire oui tu comprends il en a pour
jouer il en a pour jouer mais pour il a
occulté ta prestation tu veux dire oui
oui ouis mais c'est pas grave non c'est
pas grave enfin en tout cas c'est
rectifié dans le livre c'est rectifié
puis surtout ce que vous dites c'est que
au sujet de Louis Jouvet cette fois et
non plus de Fabrice Luini c'est c'est
Michel écrit que que lis était un
excellent évidemment comédien personne
va remettre ça en cause mais dès qu'il
se mettait Louis Jouvet à faire des
analyses sur le théâtre ce que fait un
petit peu Lucini c'était de lesbrouf et
en fait cette façon d'intellectualiser
le théâtre ça ça vous énerve quoi on
parle de jouv qui était directeur de
théâtre il n'a jamais aussi bien joué la
comédie qu'au cinéma et alors il disait
parce que il avait beaucoup de il avait
c'est génial pas le contraire magnifique
mais quand on plaisantait avec lui il
avait horreur du cinéma h mais ce que
nous connaissons moi je l'ai vu au
théâtre plusieurs fois je l'ai vu deux
fois dans ma vie c'était magnifique
aussi mais au cinéma tout le monde
connaît les prestation de de de Jouvet
donc mais il disait quand même parce que
ça l'embêtait de de d'admettre que à
côté du théâtre il y avait le cinéma où
il était génial alors voilà alors bon
alors je parle de ça parce que je vous
dites vous dites j'espère qu'un jour
Fabrice Luini redescendra à ma portée
parce que c'est ah si je pouvais jouer
avec lui et qui m'écoute ou j'aimerais
bien parce que le le principal pour un
acteur je crois la première chose c'est
comme ce que nous faisons en ce moment
tu me poses des questions tu ouvres tes
grands yeux tes oreilles et tu m'écoutes
et moi j'essaie de répondre et
enversement au théâtre c'est pareil ouis
pardon qu'est-ce que tu dis je te parle
et tu me réponds vous trouvez en gros
que Luini manque d'humilité quoi c'est
ça non je crois qu'il a été mal
élevé
alors Michel serau parle de Fabrice Lini
et puis il y a l'acteur qu'on ne peut
pas nommer par charité chrétienne
Laurent il se prend pour Jean Poiret qui
l'imite outrageusement prier point 2è
point il joue mal très mal même 3è point
mauvais esprit mauvais amis mauvais
jugement 4è point il donne des leçons de
morale à la terre entière se dit
humaniste mais n'oublie jamais son
intérêt personnel voilà dernier point il
est fait pour les tournées de
sous-préfecture où sa fausse élégance de
parvenu peut épater les casinos et enfin
il a un avis sur tout surtout dans le
sens du vent
voilà mec il est habillé pour l'hiver
là je sais pas de qui vous
parlez moi je sais très bien de qui vous
parlez oui non mais moi je pense savoir
mais je crois pas que ça puisse être lui
parce qu'il y a quand même des
contradictions je CIS que tu me dises à
qui tu penses il
va c'est oui mais il y a des choses qui
ne collent pas du tout alors si c'est
lui si c'est lui moi je pense Michel
pardon je pense qu'il joue très bien la
comédie mais bon ouais c'est la seule
chose où non je vaux dire la vérité
Michel on pense à Pierre hardarditi oh
non mais on se dit que pierrearditi joue
vachement bien la comédie donc je
comprends non non non non mais c'est
vrai qu'en tous les cas vous vous êtes
pas contrairement à ce que vous dites de
ce comédien vous êtes pas dans le sens
du vent vous êtes plutôt les les pieds
dans le plat c'est le titre du Bouin
c'est le titre il faut bien que justifie
le titre exemple vous ne comprenez pas
moi je trouve ça très bien de s'attaquer
comme ça aux vaches sacré vous ne
comprenez pas très bien pourquoi tout le
monde adore JAC Tati mais c'est pas ça
j'ai vu un film ou deux où il c'était
pas convaincant dans la drôlerie il faut
le mais là c'est mon oncle vous trouvez
ça chiant vous endormez devant la télé
enant mon et je dis la suite et la suite
après oui ah quand c'est positif pas non
mais Michel c'est vachement bien que
vous disiez ça moi je trouve ça
foridable notre épo où il y a une espèce
de consensus général national c'est
vachement bien qu'il a des gens
malheureusement franchement Victor c'est
pas un peu de la
merde écoute j'ai pas lu alors je peux
pas l vous êtes pas plus tendre avec les
hommes politiques en parlant de ah mais
mais je lui dit des méchanceté alors en
parlant de rafarin vous dites rafarin
quoi vous dites il est pas antipathique
rafarin mais on a un peu on a un peu
l'impression vous dites qu'il tient la
boutique avant la fermeture c'est vrai
ou c'est vrai c'est le comier
quoi B bien sûr ouais mais mais c'est
pas méchant non quand on parle des
commis de l'État lui c'est le commis il
attend le patron alors là là où où ça va
pas non là où ça va très bien justement
c'est que sur les services publics vous
dites qu'il faut que ça resteou euh sous
l'autorité de l'État je crois parce que
je pensais à ça l'autre jour je me
disais mais pourquoi il y aurait pas une
armée privée aussi bah il y en a en Irak
on voit ce que ça donne ça donne la
prison d'Abou GB en Irak ouiou alors
vous parlez aussi des intermittents du
spectacle Michel Serot vous dites un
truc vrai vous dites les intermittents
du spectacle c'est une appellation
épouvantable il faut il devrait déjà
manifester pour qu'on les appelle
différemment parce qu'intermittent du
spectacle c'est vrai que c'est un terme
un peu un peu hardos et alors
effectivement vous dites les choses
parce que voilà vous dites certains
figurants de cinéma refuse de tourner 3
jours pour ne pas perdre leurs acédiques
voilà là on on parle d'une chose très
délicate et très difficile c'est pas
c'est pas il y a une chose qui qui
m'étonne toujours tu voisile euh tant
mieux qu'on s'occupe de la culture et
qu'on donne les possibilités à tout le
monde mais c qui vient allumer une
arécho gaz dans un film devient
intermittent du
spectacle là il y a un abus quelque part
ouais qu'est-ce que vous dites
de de du peintre oui qui qui est chez
lui qui peint et qui est un et qui ne
vend pas ses toiles qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire je demande ce qu'il faut faire il
y a il y a quand même des critères et il
y a des métiers à risque euh j'ai eu mon
pantalon troué jusqu'à 25 ans tu
comprends je veux dire je comprends vous
dites il faut accepter le risque
inévitable du métier d'artiste c'est
vrai que c'est pas un métier très sûr
quoi c'est ce qu'on me disait quand
j'étais compositeur qui ne vend pas c
tokata ou c'est qu'est-ce qu'il va faire
le pauvre bah alors moi je voudrais
aussi qu'on s'occupe de lui et puis on
on verrait les partition puis on on
essaierait de de le faire manger aussi
et le compositeur et le peintre et et le
et l'architecte qui vend pas ses plans
et cetera et cetera donc il y a une
grande confusion là-dedans et que person
alors tout le monde noie le poisson
personne s'entend et je te grève et je
te grève pas et et vive ceci vive cela
minable ouais point alors ceci étant
Michel serro vous êtes extrêmement
solidaire des des victimes des des
injustices vous dites suis-je de droite
suis-je de gauche vous dites
effectivement l'église de droite je
préfère l'église de gauche mais votre
véritable dichotomie à vous elle s'opère
entre croyants et incroyant dans un
premier temps plutôt contre gauche et
droite et et vous dites il faut être du
côté des pauvres voilà ça c'est la seule
chose finalement qui doit nous mener
occupons-nous de des gens qu'on
rencontre dans la vie on va pas besoin
de s'expatrier très loin pour de rend
service alors simplement ouvrons nos
oreilles nos yeux et puis ouvrons notre
bourse et puis essayons de faire quelque
chose mais le reste le reste ça
m'intéresse pas beaucoup d'ailleurs vous
dites un truc formidable vous dites un
até solidaire vaut mieux qu'un câau qui
fait rien pour les autres bah oui ça me
paraît commençons par être solidaire et
puis après ça bon on ira peut-être vers
autre chose mais ne commencez pas par le
bon Dieu ne parlez pas du bon Dieu
parlez pas du bon Dieu si vous pouvez
aider quelqu'un à côté de chez vous ou
en l'oser ou n'importe où voilà
c'est'est pas mais les les grandes idées
non commencez par sortir des sous de
votre poche pour les autres je crois
vous êtes un vrai chrétien vous je suis
pas un vrai chrétien je je crois que
sans parler mais j'aime pas beaucoup
qu'on m'accuse d'être chrétien je suis
pas un exemple je suis pas mais euh je
crois que toute toutes les croyances
commencent par l'espèce d'humanité de
fraternité avec les gens et basta le
reste on verra
après je suis
d'accord
alors Michel ser vous mettez aussi les
pieds dans le plat les pieds dans le
plat les pieds dans le plat c'est le
titre du livre vous parlez de moi dans
votre boucin ah non pas de toi ah si si
si en bien vous dites
ah vous vous vous dites Thierry Ardisson
je le préfère dans Rif droite Rif gauche
que Don tout le monde en parle Thierry
hardardisson c'est docteur jackill et
mrter Hyde c'est triste de le voir ainsi
s'abîmer vous parlez de ce que je fais
dans cette émission c'est triste de le
voir ainsi s'abîmer euh c'est c'est
c'est terrible ça que vous disiez des
choses comme ça Michel je suis le même
dans les deux émissions mais avec
quelqu'un que j'aime c'est pas terrible
c'est parce que je t'aimeich il y en a
une où il y a 4 millions de gens et
l'autre où il y a 200000 personnes c'est
tout on peut pas faire la même chose
vous qui êtes un homme de spectacle vous
savez bien qu'on peut pas faire la même
chose pour 200000 personnes ou pour 4
millions de gens c'est ça qu'il faut
faire pourtant mais il y aurait jamais 4
il faut il faut vous creuser le crâne
pour faire pour plaire à tout ce public
on essaye oui oui on essaye mais voilà
mais je dis des choses aimables quand
même ah vous dites à la fin de quoi je
me mèle ce qui à mon avis ce que vous
dites de mieux à mon su
toute façon écoute je dirais que ce
livre il est fait pour rire sérieusement
et puis bah ça le reste mais il est très
bien votre bouquin parce que juste après
m'avoir dit que j'étais docteur jackill
et Mr he oui vous vous attaquez faogiel
donc ça c'estach formidable je l'attaque
ou oui oui sur Brigitte bardau ah oui
j'aime pas parce que j'aime beaucoup
Brigit bardau comme j'ai plus 20 ans
j'ai commencé avec elle à jouer la
comédie et je l'aime beaucoup je
l'admire beaucoup comme comédienne comme
chanteuse comme femme magnifique très
belle et maintenant alors on s'amuse et
on fait du scandale autour d'elle les
animaux et qu'elle s'occupent des
animaux commencez si vous n'avez pas le
courage de de de vous occuper des autres
prenez exemple sur bardau et commencez
de d'être bon avec les animaux et vous
verrez qu'un jour vous vous intéresserez
au autres aussi aux hommes aux femmes et
aux enfants donc alors basta pas de pas
de Michel ce que vous dites c'est qu'ils
l'ont manipulé pour l'amener sur le
plateau et qu'une fois qu'elle a été sur
le plateau ils l'ont massacré voilà ce
que voilà qu'est-ce que vous essayez de
faire avec
moi
du c'est la première
celle-là ça c'est la Mastercard c'est la
Master d'accord de tris bas voilà vous
dites vous dites encore des choses ah
vous dites plein de trucs non non vous
dites vous dites que Fogel était moins
arrogant avec Delon parce que Delon
l'aurait sûrement pas supporté je pense
qu'il y a de ça mais moi je dois y aller
chez lui mais j'y vais pas pourquoi j'ai
mieux venu ici parce que là on se
comprend
fais tu mas
pasénag
bien écoute on va se séparer alors
maintenant
alors comme vous avez dit que cette
émission était parfois nulle ben vous
allez avoir droit Michel serro à une
interview
nul
Michel vous devez partir vous devez
partir Michel je dois partir vous devez
partir 3 ans ou alors tu me 3 ans dans
un vaisseau spatial avec quelqu'un vous
êtes deux dans ce vaisseau spatial vous
devez partir est-ce que vous
choisissez Thierry Ardisson Marc Olivier
Fogiel ou
cé 3 ans dans le vaisseau spatial bah je
crois que je t'emmène ah c'est
gentilène ilemmène parce que bon il
essaie de de coincer un peu les gens
pour que tu cette soirée ou cette
émission a un peu de piment et cetera
c'est normal normal tu sais ce que tu as
tuas un bon fond c'est vrai c'est vrai
tu n'es pas méchant quelque fois un peu
bête
mais
alors Michel est-ce que vous préférez
être pincé mordu ou piqué piqué je le
suis
d' si c'était est-ce que vous
accepteriez d'échanger
générale contre la fin définitive des
inondations au
Bangladesh paralysie général oh là c'est
là contre la fin des inondations en
bangladesch en même temps bah oui oui
c'est intéressant sauver des viesin il
faut que je consulte un avocat tu seras
paralysé jusqu'à la fin de tes jours non
je pas te écoute franchement je ve pas
mentir pour aujourd'hui CCI je peux pas
te répondre
je comprends quand j'irai un peu moins
bien je te dirais allons-y alors
[Applaudissements]
si vous disparaissiez Michel serro à qui
confieriez-vous votre enfant à Fabrice
Lucini ou à Pierre
hardarditi je au couple car ils font
vraiment un beau
[Applaudissements]
couple vous avez commis un crime à qui
demandez-vous de cacher le corps
au gendarmes ouou ah ou c'est au
gendarmes faut pas quel est l'animal qui
embrasse le mieux Michel la
limass Michel est-ce que vous
préféreriez mourir tout de suite là
maintenant et aller au paradie ou vivre
30 ans de plus et aller en enfer
oh je crois que
je là il y a une question intéressante
vas-y on est tous les deux dans un
chalet à la neige oh quelle horreur il
fait par toi la neige il fait très très
froid on peut pas sortir du chalet on a
plus rien à manger oui vous êtes obligé
de me manger vous commencez par quelle
partie de mon
corps je sais pas pour que ça soit plus
simple j'enleverai un peu de fond de
teint ah la suivante est effectivement
plus inér encore plus bête non est-ce
que vous préférez oui un président de la
République d'extrême droite élu au
suffrage universel ou pas d'élection du
tout je pense que les c'est il y a pas
de choix parce que c'est pareil hm hm
hein ou élire ou laisser faire les
choses je pense qu'ils ont le même
résultat h Michel serro Michel c'est bon
c'est à moi Michel aimeriez-vous avoir
un nez supplémentaire oui un œil
supplémentaire un doigt supplémentaire
ou un sexe supplémentaire oh je suis
embêté parce que j'ai prends le sexe tu
verras après mais ça peut non non non
non non ce qui m'embête céit avec son
doigt là ouais carrément un doigt dans
le ouais c'est pas très joli comme
question ça quand mêmeaurais pas fait ça
rive droite rive gauche oh là là oh là
là il avait un col romain et c'était
autre chose maintenant av la ten
maintenant c'est
l'end dernière question la plus
importante Michel Serot oui vous vous
lavez les cheveux tous les combien et
ben ça va t'étonner peut-être deux fois
par jour non
ah
Michel les pieds dans le plat c'est
publié chez e édition madamees
messieurs
et
[Applaudissements]
maintenant
[Musique]
paradis
JS
c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
que c'est
vrai c'est vrai que ça faisait un moment
ça faisait un moment qu'on avait pas vu
Vanessa Paradis on est très heureux de
très heureux de vous voir Vanessa alors
lors de notre première rencontre
cétait en
1987 c'était au bain dououche l'émission
s'appelait bain de minuit c'était
l'année de J taxi et les paroles de la
chanson ét d'Étienne rag magn Serge al
la petite fille van combi vendu dis tu
le sais non pon do paslion
pardonlion pas loin million beaucoup
d'argentur monde après Chabon tout ou
avant je ne sais pas pas plus tu peux
nous chanter je taxi en tu vas pas le
chanter là non non même pas en espagnol
si je vais chanter en espagnol mais pas
ce soir pas ce soir
voilà c'était bonne min nuuit en 1987
avec Julien cler Étienne rodagille
Vanessa Paradis Étienne rodagille qui
nous a quitté récemment et pour qui je
voudrais qu'on ait une une pensée parce
que c'est quelqu'un de tout à fait
important pour nous et et pour vous ou
du commun vraiment un type exceptionnel
on l'a pas dit ici au moment où où ça
s'est passé parce que c'était comme ça
et ce soir je suis ravi de lui rendre
hommage en votre compagnie
Vanessa Étienne si tu nous regardes
commeer on me dit qu'il regarde
Étienne ouis ah ouais bien sûr il a
raison Vanessa après 5 ans d'absence au
cinéma donc le le temps de faire deux
enfants Lily Rose et Jack le temps d'un
CD qui s'appelle Bliss et d'une tournée
vous revenez dans un film absolument
bargeot une comédie de science-fiction
qui s'appelle atomicque Circus le retour
de James batille des frères poireau
alors c'est un film ovniesque hein c'est
complètement impitchable c'est une série
Z déjanté ça se passe dans un village
qui s'appelle scotlet City un village
rétroofuturiste donc au fin fond des des
US ça où on prépare une grande fête
c'est la fête de la tarte à la vache
avec une chanteuse qui s'appelle conchia
c'est vous et un cascadeur qui s'appelle
James batille voilà alors dès son
arrivée James batille séduit Concha qui
veut devenir chanteuse poussé par son
père le patron du bar qui est joué par
Jean-Pierre Mariel voilà mais la fête se
termine en catastrophe ah ah oui et
parallèlement un météorite s'écrase sur
scottlet libérant d'étranges choses
volantes gen des pieuvres des pieuvres
volante un peu comme dans les films
américains des des années 50 et là
débarque l'impressario Alan chas joué
par Benoît
pouver qui drague
Vanessa c'est un pitchap c'est bien ce
que je disais c'est ovniesque oui alors
ce que je propose d'abord avant toute
chose Vanessa c'est que vous regardiez
votre caméra et que vous dites Magneto
Serge on va voir à quoi ça ressemble
allez-y Magneto Serge sil te plaît merci
mais je ne me suis pas
présenté chiasse Alan
chi un
impressario je suis à la rechercheun
jeune
chanteuse voilà vous la connaissez c'est
incroyable c'est ma
fille devine qui est là aujourd'hui qui
je vais lever
une monsieur chier venu tout droit de la
ville c'est du c'est
duérie allez tap ça sur le ltit souon et
dégage vous êtes con chien oh mon dieu
quelle méprise excusez-moi je vous pris
pour la bon
[Musique]
s'appelle comment vre
boîord
CC
retouramesire
ave Mar et PARAD qui est notre invité ce
soir voilà sorti le 21 juillet c'est un
sensé ce film quand vous avez reçu le
scénario vous avez réagi comment j'ai
beaucoup ri beaucoup beaucoup ri tu as
pas essayé de remettre les pages dans
l'ordre c'est vrai qu'il y avait pas mal
de choses incompréhensibles et enfin des
choses pas très claires mais il y avait
un le ton qui a dans le film était déjà
dans le scénario le la bande des mots
des frères poireau qui avaient fait
beaucoup de pubs et des courtmétrages et
des clips étai vraiment insensé très
très très original et et puis eux c'est
des c'est des garçons son bourré de
talent est
tellement sincère et je suis très fière
d'être de de faire partie de ce film qui
a été fait en France par des français
avec des acteurs presque tous français
et voilà je je suis fière qui m'est
choisi voilà alors les frères poireau
effectivement ce sont des nantés hein et
ils ont fait appel pour la musique à
d'autres nantés qui s'appellent les
petits lapin de Little Rabbits euh il y
a une chanson qui est très drôle c'est
c'est la pétroleuse ptreleuse fa hier ma
ptreleuse fa
hier dès que l'on sort le soir moi JEI
en fait voir ma pétroleuse
veille quand j' de veille hier quand je
grand de veille
elle se pour moi que l'amour un de TR ma
péroleuse ma pétroleuse fa ma pétroleuse
fa ma
non non non j'ai Orlando là Orlando ve
le CP il veux le clip Orlando il va pas
nous faire chier l'année prochaine non
plus Orlando non mais Orlando il
commence à bien casser les couilles
quand même bon Orlando exige le
clip ma
P c'est elle qui m dan une
suruse quand
je
quand je suis
elle lorsque se ve soumise entre mes
jambes exc ma ptroleuse
fa ma pleuse ma ptleuse ma pétleuse des
ch tragique un avant fantastique ma
pétroleuse fait ma pétroleuse fait sous
ma jupe des sienne s sa nu des mienne
sans complexe ma
pétroleuse
péroleuse paradis avec les petits lapin
ça s'appelle ma
[Applaudissements]
pétroleuse vous calmer
oui vous allez vous calmer
oui tiens plus tiens plus
Michel en c'est une
révolte
dès queon sort le soir moi je en
fair je
crois je crois Thierry ça arrive parfois
hein je crois que les gens le public
n'accroche pas avec cette chanson non
c'est pas la peine de s'acharner on la
mettra plus tard ils aiment pas la
chanson c'est comme ça qu'est-ce que tu
veux qu'and ils ont le droit de le faire
alors le disque sort chez Barkley ce qui
veut dire que contrairement aux rumeurs
qui ont couru vous n'êtes pas dirait de
chez Barkley non enfin ça tomberait mal
au moment enfin je rechante donc non non
je sais pas mais de toute façon ils en
on fait d'autres chez barcyin ouais ceci
étant en ce moment vous semblez préférer
Vanessa Paradis votre carrière d'actrice
votre carrière de chanteuse vous dites
le cinéma c'est les vacances de la
personnalité on devient quelqu'un
d'autre on est très entouré c'est vrai
alors que chanteuse bah c'est d'une
extrême solitude non mais en plus je
préfère pas je je je préfère pas c'est
la les projets la vie qui veut ça ça se
présente comme ça et puis je je mets
plus de temps à faire les chansons
maintenant parce que je je l'ai fait un
petit peu moi avec l'aide d'autres
personnes et donc ça me prend beaucoup
de temps parce que j'essaie de faire
quelque chose oui c'est c'est long vous
dites je ne suis pas ginsbourg et puis
les enfants prennent beaucoup de temps
mais c'est c'est moi qui ve prendre
beaucoup de temps avec mes enfants parce
que j'ai rien envie de louper et que
vous les élevez vous-même quoi ah bah je
suisidé vous voulez pas les faire élever
par d'autres préfèrez les élever
vous-même ah B comme les pauvres
voilà alors euh question cinéma quand
même vous venez de tourner avec le
scénariste de la fille sur le pont qui
s'appelle Serge Freedman qui qui a
réalisé son premier film ouais ouais qui
est un petit bijou et c'est encore
quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup qui a
écrit qui écrit une histoire sublime bon
c'est je viens juste de finir de le
tourner donc c'est encore assez frais
avec un jeune acteur qui s'appelle
Vincent rôtier il faut retenir son nom
parce que c'est une une bombe atomique
une paire il a 17 ans et c'est est-ce
que tu as son portable à Vincent
retier demandé qu'il l'appelle pour on
l'appeler comme ça on va l'inviter tout
de suite Laurent oui alors en tous les
cas ce ce qu'on peut dire Vanessa c'est
vous faites pas d'effort particulierier
pour tourner en Amérique vous dites j'ai
aucune ambition internationale et vous
avez même pas d'agent à Hollywood non
non non pourquoi ben parce que je enfin
ils ont déjà ils ont des gens très très
bien ils ont pas franchement besoin de
nous quand ils ont besoin nous à moins
que ça soit un projet enfin quelque
chose de spécial mais faut faire la
course au projet j'ai l'impression faut
tout le temps être là moi qui tourne
comm même une fois tous les 36 du mois
là-bas il faudrait tourner tout tout le
temps pour jamais qu'on vous oublie puis
parce que j'ai franchement je suis moi
j'ai tout ce qu'il me faut ici en France
puis j'ai un peu l'Europe quoi je voyage
j'ai pas déjà ça me prend beaucoup de
tempsil fallait en plus que je fasse ça
là-bas puis c'est bien là-bas on montre
pas du doigt je suis ouis vous êtes SAG
finalement non bah je sais pas ouais si
bah si je pas non mais mais attends elle
élève ses enfants elle veut pas faire la
course à Hollywood vous êtes assez sage
non je suis très normal c'est très
ennuyuxê c'est bien non pas du tout
enfin je sais pas ce qu'en pense votre
Johnny Depp mais moi personnellement je
trouve ça bien bah il a pas l'air de se
plaindre il a pas l'air de se plaindre
hein apparemment ça fait longtemps que
vous êtes ensemble ça fait combien de
temps 6 ah c'est bien déjà ouais et vous
Michel vous êtes depuis combien de temps
avec votre femme 3 mois et alors vous
avez passé le cap de 3 mois
déjà ça va parce que 3 mois c'est les TR
premiers mois c'est les plus durs Michel
nous vivons ensemble depuis 3 mois nous
ne sommes pas mariés encore ou ah 3 mois
c'est les noces de bistro non oui
vanessa est toujours pas mariée non plus
hein Vanessa non benah ça va j'ai deux
enfants je suis très très marié ouais
ouais alors van ça vous n'avez toujours
pas de projet avec Johnny Depp il y a eu
cette histoire de don
quiichot pour laquelle nous avons reçu
Jean Rochefort ici l'année dernière pour
la sortie du DVD bon aventure avortée
terrible histoire évidemment et c'est
vrai qu'après le succès de de Pirate des
Caraïbes qui a fait quand même 621
millions de dollars de recettes quand
même énorme la suite est déjà en
chantier donc lui voilà il est happé par
ça et en fait effectivement vous
concentrez sur votre rôle de de maman
surtout à Los Angeles où vous passez
votre temps entre les cours de danse
pour les enfants les ateliers d'art
plastique pour les enfants le pédiatre
pour les enfants et le parc pour les
enfant il y a un poney club là-bas non
c'est vous êtes une vraie non mais ouais
mais non je suis bien comme tout le
monde quoi c'est je fais un métier
extraordinaire et puis qui sous la
lumière ou quoi mais je mais c'est pas
un reproche he si vous prenez de la COC
au Queen tous les soirs on on vous
félicite quel ennuie quel ennuie voà non
non alors entre deux tournages vous avez
votre maison avec Johnny Deb dans le sud
de la France VZ vous reposer un petit
peu VO l'adresse qui passe si vous
voulez écrire les déviations d'accès
pour le dimanche quand tu a trop de
monde ouis alors vous dites on va au
marché on cuisine on mange ils ont une
vie terriblement simple vous vivez une
espèce de de de bohème très chic un
petit peu comme dans les années 7 les
rockstars vivaient comme ça euh quand
vous voyagez avec Johnny d il y a quand
même 30 valises qui vous suivent quoi je
dire quand même c'est pas de la rigol ou
un voyage lourd c'est vrai prendre la
vaisselle aussi ou que des fringues non
c'est c'est plutôt des des repères
visuels c'est dire les les meubles non
par exemple je vais te donner un
exempleur le drap qui recouvre la table
à langer par exemple pour que les
enfants soient habitués à la couleur du
drap Vanessa prend ce drap tu vois voilà
c'est tout c'est c'est vrai hein oh
c'est beau comme vous dites ça mais non
mais aussi parce que moi les enfants ils
vivent une vie de boame on enfin c'est
vrai qu'on leur a pas tellement demandé
leur AVI ils ont pas l'air de s'en
plaindre mais il faut quand même pas les
changer de maison sans arrêt sans qu'ils
aient des choses ou qu'il reconnaissent
quoi pour pas trop Venessa Paradis et
Johnny Deb c'est un couple parfait c'est
le bonheur absolu donc on va faire une
interview je fous la
merde Vanissa vous êtes toujours
amoureuse de Johnny Depp ouais vous êtes
toujours pas marié donc non vous trouvez
pas qu'il est un peu moins bon en ce
moment tuétais fou non
il a pas un peu grossi non ah non non
c'est vrai qu'il a une vilain verrue
plantaire ou
pas c'est pas dommage d'être tout le
temps séparé non sérieux justement on
n'est pas tout le temps séparé il vous
néglige pas là non non c'est quand qui
vous a dit je t'aime pour la dernière
fois tout à l'heure le dernier cadeau
qui vous a fait c'est quoi une valise
une valise quoi non je sais pas si j'ai
j'ai eu des belles roses pour la fête
des ah il est vachement intentionné en
plus c'est génial il c'est c'est et
quand quand il offre des fleurs il dit
pas sa secrétaire de le faire c'est lui
qui va vraiment les acheter au magasin
ouais ouais c'est bien il noublie jamais
votre anniversaire non celui de votre
rencontre non plus non mais c'estàd si
l'interview c'est pour savoir s'il est
parfait moi je vous le confirme tout de
suite il est parfait ou vous vous
engueulez parfois quand même bah bien
sûr c'est pour ça qu'il est parfait
parce qu' il oublie de relever la
cuvette des des des toilettes non non
jamais c'est un mec formidable
non sérieusement c'est quoi qui vous
énerve le plus chez
lui qu'on le fasse pas nous il a des
défauts mais j'aime ses défauts ah ouais
ah ouais d'accord ah oui vous l'aimez
alors d'accord non mais ça il il il est
pas ordonné il estraîné ses chaussettes
bah ouais mais j'aimerais pas qu'il
range toutes ses affaires en plus non
mais c'est c'est ah oui d'accord ou vous
êtes fol de lui mais non mais si il on
va dire il a un petit peu in tempérament
de feu ouais et que c'est pas toujours
très facile mais mais mais moi ça me
plaît bien quand même ah c'est qui allô
Vincent
retier salut c'est Laurent baffille tu
es sur Paris là il peut passer peut-être
oui bonjour Vincent mtoi le C on est à
l'antenne tu es sur Paris c'est vrai
est-ce que tu peux passer s'il te plaît
à la ple Saint-
neé c'est Vanessa qui maintenant c'est
Vanessa Paradis qui a parlé de toi elle
a dit que tu étais formidable et je te
la passe donc mmetoi le cul on
t'attend moi aussi je t'embrasse
je te passe Vanessa vous êtes fou
allô non mais c'est
toi non
mais c'est mais ouais mais je pour rien
j'ai juste voulu dire des
gentillet allô allô non en plus c'est
vraiment il dit de venir mais non ils
veulent que tu n'en viens pas faire la
Prom non tuas le
temps il va faire la pré promo de mon
ange oui oui non il y a plein de mond
non mais il a mieux à faire il a la fête
de la musique c'est ça c'est bien c'est
son la fin vous êtes pas un peu
amoureuse de lui vous oh non mais j'ai
beaucoup de tendresse pour lui je
l'adore il est c'est un mec bien et
c'est un super faon on est samedi il y a
plus la fête de la musique samedi il
faut qu'il vienne ouais tu
connaism allô AC Vanessa elle
t'adore
ça va je serai Johnny DEAP je serai
jaloux moi
elle t'adore hein
elle a dit tu as 18 balets tu es hyper
mignon elle a dit même il venait d'avoir
18 ans elle a même chanté enfin il dit
que c'est une belle aventure avec toi
mais qui passe 2 minutes va nous
raconter bon à tout à l'heure on
t'attend
hein je crois qu'il va passer par il va
mettre les choses au
point bien alors
bon de deux trois petites questions puis
voilà donc il est parfait c'est Johnny
de évidemment il râle pas quand il faut
descendre la poubelle non enfin mais r
il est pas il est il est pas parfait
c'est pour ça qu'il est parfait il a des
manies qui vous énervent quand même oh
là là ah quand même il y en a quand même
ah vous l'avez déjà chopé en train de
regarder un film porno non
non bon mais c'est sans
espoir
CC le film s'ppelle Atom
couramten
[Musique]
patri comment ça va ça va
vous êtes ici pour l'Américain donc le
nouveau film de Patrick teamsit avec
Thierry lermit Émilie de Ken Richard
Berry Marianne de niicour et Laurent
Dutch sorti le 7 juillet je vais faire
le pitch ah oui on va voir si j'y arrive
et on va voir si je comprend surtout
ouais alors c'est l'histoire d'un mec
persuadé qu'il est américain et qui
comprend pas pourquoi il a pas le droit
de vivre dans le pays qu'il aime voilà
ça c'est très bien c'est très clair non
c'est très bien c'est très bien c'est
très bien c'est pas drôle c'est très
bien non mais ça c'est le pitch he de
toute façon voilà alors il pense
américain il mange américain il vit
américain mais il est français VO fait
chier américain voilà et il est pas né
au bon endroit il est né ici et et
Thierry l'ermite la semaine dernière
parlait du film et il disait que
finalement c'est un peu comme un mec qui
est persuadé d'être une femme dans un
cord d'homme enfin transsexuel il le dit
d'ailleurs on me ferait moins chier si
je voulais changer de sexe ah ça veut
dire que c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
vouloir être américain quand on se quand
on est français on a le droit de se
sentir américain vouloir c'est la
liberté de circulation pourquoi on est
né quelque part et on doit y rester
voilà voilà donc c'est un peu c'est
c'est le sujet du film absolument alors
Laurent dudge dans le film donc grâce à
l'avocat Thierry l'ermite va réussir à
inquiéter les États-Unis et à créer un
51e état du côté de Merlette là c'est un
peu comme si le village d'asérix
demandait son son rattachement à Rome
quoi ouais c'est le village d'asérix
mais il veut être romain quoi ce village
ouis ouais ouais voilà en début de promo
non non non non non j'ai j'ai déjà oUI
NON au milieu de la promo pourquoi on
sent déjà que tu en as plein le cul de
parler de ton ah non pas du tout j'ai
jamais entendu parler comme ça on est en
fin d'né ça joui c'est vous qui êtes
crevé les gars bon je le refaire
énergiquement allez allez vas-y la
patate kry la PAT laille bordel la quiz
donc c'est l'histoire d'un mec qui est
persuadé qu'il est américain et il
comprend pas pourquoi il a pas le droit
de vivre dans le pays qu'il aime voilà
alors il pense américain il mange
américain il vit américain mais il est
français voilà am bon endroit voilà mais
grâce à un avocat cynique et froid qui
s'appelle Thierry l'ermite ils vont
réussir à inquiéter les États-Unis en
décrétant lesmerlettes 51e État des
États-Unis voilà c'est un peu comme si
le village d'astterrix demandait son
rattachement à Rome en
fait en
fait plus en forme que jamais attends
attends ah non vous êtes en forme pour
des gars qui finissent une année attends
c'est bien c'est bien il peut faire
beaucoup mieux il y en a beaucoup plus
sous le capot il va te le prouver tout
suite encore une fois donc c'est
l'histoire d'un mec qui est persuadé
qu'il est américain et il comprend pas
pourquoi il a pas le droit de vivre dans
le pays qu'il aime voilà alors il pense
américain il mange américain il vit
américain mais il est français voilà il
est allé au bon endroit voilà mais grâce
à un avocat cynique et froid qui
s'appelle Thierry l'ermite ils vont
réussir à inquiéter les États-Unis en
décrétant les Merl 51e État des
États-Unis voilà c'est un peu comme si
le village d'Astérix demandait son
rattachement à R
si non mais c'est pas grave on rajoutera
des syllabes au
montage ah non j' non non c'était un gag
cé la deuxè FO pe dire c'est qui VO il
est làbas qui nous parle qui me parle
qui nous parle ce qu'on peut dire c'est
qu'il voit l'Amérique un peu comme les
immigrants du 18e un peu comme
l'eldorado bien sûr mais oui [__] les
peres que je lui tends mais prendsles
les perche me dire il bien prise il
estou il a plus l'habitude de faire de
la télé tu saisavant il v la télé tout
JS tu me ses moins professionnel
qu'est-ce que je devrais faire là ça
c'est quoi la perche je te tend des
perche je te par il aime pas l'Amérique
pour ce qu'elle est mais pour ce qu'elle
représente exactement son Amérique c'est
l'Amérique du divertissement le
Coca-Cola ouais c'est c'est Peter Pan
quoi c'està-dire que son Amérique à lui
c'est un peu comme un monde imaginaire
un monde perdu qui existe plus qui qui
est plus comme il l' il s'attend à avir
John Wayne déboulé au coin d'une rue
pour sauver la la veuve et l'orphelin et
il s'en fout de savoir ce qui se passe
et tout le contexte un petit peu
difficile aujourd'hui que que qu'en
globe l'Amérique lui pour lui c'est pas
du tout ça quoi c'est vraiment
l'Amérique d'Hollywood de la dernière
séance qui met le cinéma à fermé
aujourd'hui tu l'as bien
lui pas regarde à bouler à traîner qui
t'aide pas qui regarde son téléphone
pendant que tu rames bien alors que vous
allez faire ça va nous faire un break
pendant que téléphone vous allez
regarder votre caméra mag
attention l'Américain le nouveau film
avec
[Musique]
la je su persuadé que vous n coloriez
jodassin l'Amérique l'Amérique c'est
bizarre je s il senti dans le taxi déjà
il fait une BO avec a on s'attendait pas
c'était moins musi pas grave c'est bien
[Musique]
préè
age toaméricain bande originale du
film est coup voilàs fort que pour moi
mais qu'il faut dire Pat c'est que
l'Américain le scénario s'inspire de de
de fait réel de votre vie parce que
depuis l'âge de 14 15 ans vous avez vécu
ce ce rêve américain vous alle
régulièrement aux États-Unis et vous
aviez une idée au moment de votre
adolescence qui était d'importer des des
skateboards et d'exporter de la
ratatouille voilà c'est vrai qu'on
allait régulièrement avec des potes aux
États-Unis qu'on avait ce rêve américain
là-bas tout est possible une idée un
dollar et c'est possible et donc c'est
vrai qu'on y a cru et que et qu'on y
était tous les jours à chercher donc des
des idées un moment on était dans les
croissaneries et la dernière idée
c'était la rate àou j'étais avec Fabrice
Nataf mon copain qui exatron de Virgine
ouais voilà qui est aujourd'hui chez im
et tout et et on se réunissait on se
disait on part on part en juin on part
aux États-Unis en juin pas avec les
bocos non on allait la fabriquer là-bas
on cétait ratou était fabriqué là-bas ah
ben oui centre français du commerce
extérieur on était rencardé surtout on
était un peu pointu ah d'accord oui oui
avec les BET Maurice Chevalier dans le
juk box on se disait on va faire un bar
français qu'on va appeler la ratatouille
et mon rêve américain s'est arrêter là
où le film commence c'est-à-dire que
Francis Farge commence ou quand vous
allez chercher le visa quoi ouais
exactement on se retrouve place de la
Concorde au au consulat d'Amérique et on
dit bah voilà on a une idée on voudrait
oui quoi et ben on voudrait exporter la
ratatouille on voudrait vivre là-bas
très bien c'est possible oui c'est
possible vous avez un père américain une
mère américaine non un frère une sœur
peut-être non un parent proche non vous
êtes marié à une Américaine non c'est
pas possible alors et voilà on s'est
retrouvé euh un après-midi de juin place
de la Concorde aéré comme comme Francis
Farge dans le film et on avait perdu
notre rêve américain quoi parce que CZ
ça vous qui vivez à Los Angeles souvent
est-ce qu'on trouve de la ratou j'ai pas
vu de ratou tu vois voilà jamais
personne l'idée n'est pas morte jamais
personne l'a fait mais là ça va donner
des idée il y a des gens qui vont
déposer le brev attends les croissants
ça paraarissait aussi con aujourd'hui il
y a plein de Croissanterie ouais mais il
faut la faire la RAT c'est
impressionnant oui c y cro mer vous y
croyez Michel ah bien s voyez que je
suis pas malade non mais tu aurais fait
fortune tu aurais peut-être gagné plus
de blé qu'avec le cinéma bah c'està dire
qu'aujourd'hui je vendrais de la RAT àou
et à Los Angeles alors voilà va savoir
quel est le destin qu'il faut choisir
quoi alors c'est un enjeu la sorti de ce
film pour vous non vous êtes stressé un
peu patri pas du
tout reprends la
patate je savais que ça lu F plaisir ou
pas du tout du tout stressé du tout
stressé alors pas du tout mais pas du
tout du tout pas du tout stressé prenez
des risques là quand même non aucun oua
vous m'avez dit une fois une phrase
géniale il y a beaucoup de risqu à ne
pas prendre de risque ah oui exactement
al je maintiens c'est vrai que tant
qu'on croit qu'on est dans le risque on
prend moins de risque que quand on pense
qu'il y a pas de risque voilà et puis il
y a un proverbe génial c'est les bateaux
sont à l'abri dans les ports mais ils ne
sont pas faits pour cela ah ça reste
valable pour moi absolument je préfère
casser en mer que de rester au port
ouais il y a un risque que vous prenez
plus en tous les cas c'est celui de
venir sur les plateaux télé quoi on vous
voit plus ouais on voit plus au début de
votre carrière vous étiez très généreux
avec la télé vous étiez là vousz Maré
moi la première fois que j'ai eu un f
rire sur un plateau de télé c'est double
jeu avec Patrick il y avait les les les
noirs qui tenaient les albartes comme ça
il leur toucher les couilles et c'est la
première fois où je me suis marré et je
me suis dit [__] mais non mais je me
suis dit je me suis dit mais c'est un
boulot on peut rire en le faisant parce
que jusque-là je le faisais quand même
encore plus sérieusement que maintenant
et je me suis dit on peut rire en le
faisant et ça a é voilà ça a été
vraiment pour moi une révélation cette
émission et depuis on vous a plus jamais
beaucoup vu mais alors est-ce que c'est
moi qui ai changé ou la télé qui a
changé non c'est vous parce que vous
aviez c'est une mauvaise réponse vous me
connaissiez pas avant c'est moi qui ché
ça fait 20 minutes que tu es là tuas
touché les couilles de
personne non c'est vrai qu' moment vous
étiez à un moment Patrick vous étiez
profession invité c'est vrai mais bien
sûr vous dites les gens pensent que je
fais que invité à la télé il ce que je
faisais à côté donc je vais faire autre
chose et vous avez rompu complètement
les ponts avec la télé trop parce qu'
pas question non plus de venir soit tous
les jours soit jamais donc là vous avez
commencé à plus jamais venir il y a eu
une rupture d'affectivité avec le public
vous le savez ça avec avec le public
télé vous voulez dire non le public en
général le public ah non peut-être pas
si ah si si si le public a cru que vous
le que vous le snobiez bien sû c'est pas
parce que fogier n'est pas là qu'il faut
prendre sa place non je veux dire c'est
pas se jeter surtout tiens l'autre il
est passé à
2050 non et restez vous-même restez
vous-même non mais vous savez que je
vous en veux non mais de toute façon ah
oui c'est ça je sens il veut pas
déconner avec moi mais sérieux Mo j'ai
pas changé parce que vous nous manquez
ah bah avec plaisir ah si c'est une
déclaration d'amour là je je bis bien
sûr c'est
çais allez un bisou un
bisou ok là je le crois là ça va je
comprends pardon ah c'est la grande
réconciliation ce soir d'accord ok non
mais c'est vrai voilà je le prends bien
d'accord d'accord ça ça n'est que ça ok
vous avez peur de quoi en venant à la
télé de vous banaliser de vous oui tout
ce qui est rare est précieux il a raison
de se protéger vous avez peur de quoi
Pat suff C vous avez peur d'un d'un
dérapage ah pas du tout non c'est pas du
dérapage puisque en général c'est moi
qui les provoque les dérapag donc c'est
pas du dérapage pas Dieu donné vous avez
pas peur de
déraper mais Dieu donné il dérape pas en
télé il dérape entre les télés die donné
moi j'ai jamais vu qu'il avait dérapé en
télé j'ai vu quelqu'un qui l'a fait est
rappé en en télé hein votre ami comment
il s'appelle le mec là mais si celui qui
a il est passé à 20h50 dans le bouquin
de Michel ou voilà non mais c'est vrai
vous avez peur de quoi vous avez pas
peur de déraper vous mîtrisez par j'ai
pas peur de déraper j'ai peur de ne plus
rien avoir à raconter j'aime bien quand
venir ici avoir la patate et puis tout
d'un coup un peu déstabilisé avoir des
choses à raconter si vous en faites tous
les jours vous vous répétez il y a un
truc et vous devenez bon client et bon
client de quoi qu'est-ce que alors
Laurent est-ce que vous êtes heureux
vous de faire de la télé deevenir à la
télé oui ça va c'est PL ouais ouais
toute façon vous dites que ça sera
toujours plus agréable que le métier de
votre père hein ouais bah forcément et
on a moins les doigts dans dans la merde
ouais il est plombier c'est on est MOS
obligé de déboucher des trucs donc c'est
forcément quelque chose de de plus
gratifiant même si c'est un métier qui
est qui est très nécessaire et surtout
en ce moment où mon chauffau a pété et
on est laissz bien les cordonniers les
mois bien chaussés parce que j'en
profite de faire une annonce pour mon
père si tu pouvais venir la semaine
prochaine ça serait bien parce que là je
commence vraiment en avoir marre c'est
un chauffau 100 l je peux pas le le
sortir tout seul vous av encore plein de
rêve ah ouais heureusement vous mariez
ouais faire l'amour
déjài
queit il nous
racontéé ptif en fusion là si ça pouvait
arriver dans pas trop
longtempel quel genre de fille vous
cherch n'importe laquelle une
consentante
ouais déjà et non non je crois que
trouvé
ouais ouais j'ai trouvé je suis très
épris je sale Patrick avec ça en
permanence donc voilà vous êtes sur une
bonne piste là ça va il y a pas vous
avez pas besoin de lancer un je suis
très épris malheureusement je crois pas
que ce soit forcément partagé mais ah
mais on est plein de rêves donc on bosse
et puis le principal dans un rêve c'est
pas forcément d'y arriver mais c'est de
courir pour l'atteindre elle sait que
vous avez le pris en
Gabin ouais j'ai peut-être dû lui dire
elle a peut-être dû le savoir mais ça
elle est pas trop làdedans elle est pas
trop branché cinéma quand il sera payé
le prix Jean Gabin là viendra
peut-être
[Musique]
bonjour vous êes bien chez thierryerm je
tourne un film sérieux laissez-moi un
message
bip un film sérieux j'ai dû me tromper
de de téléphone là je rappellerai plus
tard bonjour vous êtes bien chez Richard
ber je mange Yaour ça un message bip ah
écoute Richard je voulais juste en
profiter pour embrasser ta femme et mes
gosses le pire dans la pub c'est pas de
faire la pub c'est les gens qui en
parlent bonjour vous êtes bien chez
Monsieur Madame désolé laiss un message
bip je suis avec Patrick tout se passe
bien il a pris son petit tricot il a les
slips marqués avec les jours de la
semaine donc il pourra pas se tromper il
a sa casquette il a le produit pour le
soleil non non je vous le passe 2
secondes je viens vendredi vendredi je
suis là c'est normal si on a pas crevé
bonjour vous êtes bien cheztia Casta si
vous nêtes pas Patricks laissez-moi un
message bonti faut arrêter de m'appeler
maintenant par Cheon je suis très épr de
quelqu'un et tu as compris que ce
n'était pas toi donc arrête de bousill
mon répondeur
mess
c'est Pat je ne laisserai pas de message
voil bonjour vous êtes bien chez Florent
P si c'est pour un conseil fiscal
laissez-moi un message
B Flor P bon ben maintenant voilà ça y
est j'ai acheté le disque tes problèmes
fiscaux sont réglés maintenant tu repars
ou si tu as un autre problème tu viens
nous voir tu fais un disque puis sinon
tu peux tu peux vendre Leit qui est
planqué
sous bonjour vous êtes bien chez zan un
truc pour les cheveux laiss un message
on mérite pas de te parlerou on mérite
pas on pas le droit de parler on peut
pas en face c'est pas possible ça c'est
vrai bonjour vous êtes chez Gérard
Armand je sais j'ai mué vous pouvez
laisser un message s'il vous plaît ah
Gérard j'ai souffert pour toi j'ai
souffert je t'ai vu chez Thierry
hardardisson et il voulait raconter une
histoire habide à ta place il a mal
raconté c'est pas une histoire habide
Gérard quand c'est toi qui la raconte je
te jure elle est drôle if if between non
tu sais tu sais tu sais pourquoi tu sais
pourquoi je l'ai planté parce que j'ai
pas fait if if between between non et
même la main elle est vers l'intérieur
c'est if if between VO tu VO voilà if if
between tu la connais tu la raconteras
pas comme ça ti est-ce
raconter c'est pas grave pasve connais
la chute mais ENF ça peut aider non
c'est un mec Gérard excuse-moi si je la
rate mais c'est un mec non c'est
l'histoire àit c'est vrai qu'on prend
des bides etorme c'est un mec qui qui
qui qui veut apprendre l'anglais il
consulte comme ça toutes les petites
annonces et vous apprenez l'anglais en
en 6 semaines 3000 € et il regarde en 9
semaines 4000 € il a pas les moyens il
doit vraiment apprendre l'anglais il est
comme un fou et tout d'un coup il voit
une annonce apprenez l'anglais en 3
jours 10 € il se dit c'est pas possible
il y a une coquille C'est pas c'est
c'est c'est pas enfin c'est pas la somme
c'est pas mais en même temps il est il
est très embêté il est au chômage oui
mais Gérard l'a fait encore mieux que
toi oui et donc il dit il faut que
j'aille voir quand même enfin c'est
c'est peut-être une coquille mais c'est
peut-être 100 € et pas 10 € et dans 100
€ je peux encore me la payer il arrive
et là et là il sonne à la porte il est
là avec sa petit annonce il est tout
navré il sait que c'est une coquille et
il y a un hindou qui ouvre et qui ouvre
comme ça la porte il fait oui
excusez-moi sœur je j'ai lu apprenez
l'anglais pour pour 10 € en 3 jours
c'est c'est c'est peut-être une bêtise
mais est-ce que c'est c'est vrai il fait
if
voilà
histoire que j'ai histoire que j'ai
planté tris fois de suite elle est très
bien racontée mais ça reste quand même
une histoire habide non puis c'est
courageux de raconter la fin puis après
de repartir c'est pas courageux c'est
kamikas c'est la différence entre
quelqu'un qui va perdre à quelqu'un qui
va gagner moi j'ai perdu non ah ben oui
alors qu'il a qu'il arrive vcent Rotier
est parmi nous
V
voilà Vincent retierà émission bonsoir
Vincent bonsoir On va vous donner on va
vous donner une vous donner une chaise
bonsoir alors elle vous adore vous savez
elle vous adore elle a parlé de vous
avec les larmes dans les yeux quand on a
dit il faut qu'il vienne a dit on va pas
le déranger ce soir bien parce que comme
c'est sa première grande télé il aurait
flippé s'il avait été programmé alors
que là comment ça
va un pe stress ti une carte de bon
client tout de suite déjà une carte de
mec qui est venu déjà déjà bonjour aussi
alors bonjour à toutond voilà
Patrick
Michelon voilà tu as tu as eu un prix
déjà on a tous voté donc maintenant
poszli des question il va pas faire un
one man ch je lu demande comment
Comce une vraie maman ah c'est c'est une
femme tout pour j'aimerais beaucoup que
la ça soit ma maman tu as beaucoup de
chance Vincent tu sais oui alors comment
ça s'est passé alors ce tournage mets
ton micro dans la bouche comment ça
s'est passé dans la bouche elle était
gentille avec toi ouais oui oui très
gentil le premier jour ça s'est passé
comment quand quand vous êtes arrivé
tous les deux tu la connaissais déjà tu
l'avais rencontré Vanissa une fois ouais
tu veux te marier avec elle
elle t'impressionne tu as le trac quand
tu la vois
maintenant ça aussi un peu un tout petit
peubut mais au début plus tu tu
l'embrasses dans le film
non prépar ça en tout cas tu as du PO
parce que c'est ton premier tour de
manège et tu roules déjà en Ferrari ça
fait plaisir prier pas ton
prier il a eu de Oscars qu'est-ce qu' a
fait avant il a eu de Oscars mais je
lappète
pas'pp de christop rou ou un téléfilm
qui s'appelle la classe du brevet ouais
de Edwin Belly ah Christophe rouia c'est
celui qui av fait le Gone du Chabin
ouais ah c'était mortel ça tuas pas fait
une pue pour yop
non faut le mettre à l'aise quand même
un petit peu il est juste là non non
mais Ben cétait juste pour ça
voilà peir un ver protéger protéger
c'est c'est pas évident surtout la
tienne desmission quoi ce serait autre
chose un truc un peu protge là on
protège Bou on verrouille verouille on
cro céit l'école des f on a tout
verrouillé il va être protégé là il
pourra pas le choper tu tu veux qu'on le
protège oui je on va le protèger il il s
bien se défendre ne l'approche pas tou
il touche pas ne va pas nous pourrir
Michel protégezle franchement les clubs
échangistes alors ça se passe
comment il est il est Michel là il a
pris 50 ans de purgatoire non il est pas
mal il est pas mal il s'est pas perdu
non
plus non c'est pas la peine trop tard
c'est foutu pour toi tu vas cramer chez
l'andru bien on termine ces messieurs
donc bonjour vous êtes bien chez Lionel
Jospin je vais revenir laissez-moi un
message bip on s'est pas ennuyer sans
toi ouais on s'est pas ennuyer sans toi
non mais non mais c'est vrai c'est pas
un moulin faut pas venir partir venir
partir faut venir rester s'il veut mais
tu as progressé au tennis pendant ton
temps de vacances parce que moi je l'ai
vu jouer une fois c'est fathétique
heinou pas terrible bonjour vous êtes
bien chez dieud donné si c'est pour la
vérité si jeement 3 merci de laisser un
message bip qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire qu'il y a Dieu
donné d'un côté le côté le monde non
c'est quoi cette histoire die doné moi
j'ai pas suivi c'est quoi Pat va te
raconter tuas pas les GES frçais mais
qu'est-ce qu'il a il a un spectac qui
s'appelait le divorce de Patrick que
j'ai vu qui est pas mal plutôt plus que
pas mal moi jeçis rire non mais c'est
bien de le dire c'est vraiment que sur
scène c'est super drôle quoi et c'est
vrai que voilà et puis il y a eu un
débordement chez Fogiel et puis un
débordement un sketch drôle ou pas drôle
c'est même pas un débordement parce que
là déjà je prends partie voilà sketch
drôle ou pas drôle c'est pas important
ça c'est pas grave jusque-l on a tous
fait des trucs drôles ou pas drôles et
et c'est après c'est entre-temps moi que
je trouve que ça se complique c'est
entre les sketchs donc je dirais ben je
sais pas
quoi entre les sketchs fais pas de
sketch quoi et quel message tu lui
laisses alors fais pas de sketch entre
les sketch c'est sketch ou pas sketch je
suis paumé moi quand c'est lui qui parle
ou quand c'est pas lui qui parle si
c'est lui qui parle quand il parle ça
c'est vraiment déplacé quand quand tout
d'un coup c'est un personnage ça va donc
que quand il parle nazi qui mettent un
un vrai uniforme de nazi quand il
continue de parler nazi entre les
sketchs sans avoir le costard et dans le
monde et à la télé ça ça me gêne
vraiment parce que c'est plus que ça ça
me gêne ça me ça me ça me ça m'orpile ça
me rend fou Patrick toi dans tes sketchs
moi je me souviens quand je te voyais
sur scène à l'époque il y avait des
trucs incroyable on va parvenir parvenir
sur les crevettes parceon a beaucoup
parlé mais il y avait un moment où tu
disais mon grand-père était acteur dans
Choa il a fini manquin chez mon savon
quand même ah oui absolument mais
imagine si die disait ça oui sauf que
moi j'ai écouté un truc il y a deux
trucs que je voudrais dire moi un j'ai
fait un sketch qui s'appelle ils sont
partout non mais parce que comme
ça ouais c'était les catholiques les
juifs et les Arabes mais j'ai eu les les
j'ai eu les compliments d' Yasser Arafat
donc c'est-à-dire que c'est plus c'est
plus pareil quoi c'est-à-dire que tout
d'un coup euh c'est vrai que je dis et
dans un sketch où je disais cette vie
cette fois arabe pas de peau mais je
disais le colon israélien qui va sur le
mur des lamentations et il se repentit
et il dit après avoir tabassé un
Palestinien pourquoi je l'ai pas tué
pourquoi je l'ai pas tué donc Arafat a
retenu ça et puis euh le Juif retient
les catholiques et puis le catholique
retient les musul il y en avait pour
tout le monde ou l'époque c'est des
spectacles que tu écrivais avec Bruno
gasscio et Jean-François alin et
Jean-François guignol cétait et donc ce
sont vraiment des mais quand tu dis
alors l'acteur dans Choa et le mannequin
chez mon saavant normalement ça aurait
dû faire un scandale à l'époque ça
passait assez inaperçu enfin tout le
monde trouver ça non ça pass pas non non
ça sautait au plafond quand même mais il
y a il y a un ensemble et puis c'est
pareil c'est sur scène quoi je suis pas
je suis pas dans la rue au Bistro avec
des propos comme ça quoi c'est c'est
juste la différence c'est c'est chumarur
il conduit à 360 km he sur circuit
est-ce qu'il a le droit de de conduire
comme ça sur une autoroute là je trouve
que Dieu donné il conduit à 350 kmh sur
autoroute
inverse voilà Patrick le film s'appelle
l'Américain avec Laur
Dutch bande originale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fois P pas à la maison
est pe pas dire où elle est est che un
am pas tu la laiss aller chez am mais
elle fait ce qu'elle veut y ou sa vous
êtes un couple moderne oh bah oui un
vieux couple moderne bon qu'est-ce qu'il
y a qu'est-ce que tu veux me dire faut
que tu a non c'est pas on t' assz vu
c'est qu'il faut que tu AES coucher à
ton âge ça m'aurait fait plaisir deer un
peu prend pas comme
ça on se RRA nous ah oui on se RRA
au revoir au revoiroup
roir au revoir gamin au roir biô alors
ma ché
alors pas
laisserire
je
reviendrai on arrive à dire des bêtises
tu regrettes j'auraisv sur le plateau
ment que vous êtes un magnifique acteur
ah bon et j'accueille maintenant Vincent
[Musique]
payon
bonsoir bonsoir Vincent payant vous
connaissez tout le monde oui Laurent m'a
dit s'il y a payant moi ah ouis ah ouais
il m'a dit je inconditionnel malgré le
fait que j'ai pas lu le livre ouais mais
malgré tout ouais j'aime bien le nom je
trouve ça voilà
pon alors Vincent payon député PS de la
somme de 1997 à 2002 dirigeant depuis
1994 du du PS cofondateur avec Arnaud
Montebourg du NPS le Nouveau Parti
socialiste vous avez présidé la mission
parlementaire française sur le
blanchiment ce qui nous vaut un livre
qui s'appelle les milards noirs du
blanchiment chez Hette littérature voilà
mais AAR avant je voudrais vous
féliciter de votre récente élection
comme député européen eu et vous
demander de commenter quelques
déclaration vous avez pu faire suite au
résultat de cette élection alors vous
avez déclaré rafarin c'est c'est fort
rafarin n'a pas une mission à accomplir
mais une démission à donner
oui le sentiment que j'ai eu c'était
qu'on était un peu encore dans la dans
la comédie après le résultats des
élections puisqueah d'un côté ça fait
trois fois qu'il y a manifestement une
une sanction assez forte et en même
temps la réaction de mes mes amis
politiques était de dire ça va très mal
la France va de plus en plus mal il y a
de plus en plus de chômeurs mais
gardonsle encore 3 ans pour préparer
l'alternance moi je considère que si on
pense que ces difficultés sont réelles
ce que je crois ben il faut lui dire à
ce momentl de partir dire c'est que la
fin rne risque de durer 3 ans voilà et
vous dites il faut dissoudre l'Assemblée
nationale le seul moyen d'avoir un
gouvernement qui a une certaine
légitimité ça serait de revoter voilà
c'est ce que j'ai dit voilà il a dit a
sens de la formule il a dit rafarin ne
réforme pas la France il la déforme mais
il a un auteur vous avez un auteur non
il y a un
mec c'est bien c'est bien écrit il
s'appelle payon payon il est député de
la Somme il a le sens de la formule ça
s c'est pas moi c'est écrit
là cous moi je bien enfin il y a quand
même Hollande Fabius troscan auri Lang
de la Noé qui qui finalement on sait pas
encore lequel va être candidat en 2007
donc il y a cette espèce de guerre
picrocoline qui est insupportable aussi
vous êtes bien d'accord alors les
solutions Vincent on a 10 secondes non
attends non non il y a pas de solution
il y a pas de solution parce que Vincent
à l'intérieur de son courant au Parti
socialiste qui s'appelle le Nouveau
Parti socialiste le NPS qui l'a fondé
avec Arnaud mtebourg il y a du grabuge
aussi c'estàd quand même à l'intérieur
de votre soucourant il y a du grabuge il
y a la première biographie de Montebourg
qui va sortir le 18 août écrite par gu
Benamou chez Stock et Montebourg vous
soupçonne d'avoir alimenté le biographe
en lui balançant des des horreurs sur
lui non c'est pas ça ce ce non non non
c'est pas ça je vaux vous répondre
franchement c'est un sujet vous savez
parce qu'on va peut-être en parler avec
Montebourg on a formé un couple on nous
a appelé Starski et Hutch s'est opposé à
beaucoup de gens on nous a appelé pompon
et modeste on nous a appelé et cetera et
ça un peu intrigué que deux un peu plus
jeunes qui prennent des risques j'étais
porte-parole du Parti socialiste je suis
seul dans son his va donner sa démission
on a fait ce congrès dans vous parler
voilà donc on est très observé et
certains ont eu le sentiment qu'il y
avait entre nous et on voulu jouer un
petit peu avec ça des dissentiments mais
ce n'est pas la réalité ce que je crois
mais on verra quand elle sortira cette
biographie c'est que vous l'attendez
c'est une bonne chose pour Guig Benamou
en tout cas euh c'est que je crois que
Arnaud mondbourg quand il en a eu
connaissance a pas toujours reconnu un
certain nombre d'éléments qui faisaient
partie de ces combats politiques voilà
mais je crois que cette affaire est
derrière nous et entre nous vous AZ l'
un pe réconcilier puisque vous le
remerciez dans dans l'ouverture du livre
qui vous amène ce soir s'appelle donc
les milliards noirs du blanchiment chez
achè littérature alors le blanchiment
bah c'est c'est quoi c'est laver
l'argent sale quoi c'est l'argent de la
de la drogue la prostitution de la
corruption de la contrefaçon du trafic
d'armes trafic de personnees trafic
d'organes maintenant qui se développe
beaucoup en Europe ça a produit de
l'argent beaucoup d'argent on dit que le
le le la somme total du crime est
au-delà du produit intérieur brut de la
France ça veut dire c'est plus de 200
milliards d'euros et ça ne de croîre
malgré toutes les dénonciations
internationales mais quand vous avez cet
argent venu de la prostitution du trafic
de personne vous pouvez pas le dépenser
tout de suite donc il faut arriver à le
remettre dans des circuits pour le
blanchir ça venait des des
blanchisseuses d'Al capapone qui passé
par bon et donc il faut rendre cet
argent qui vient du crime il faut lui
donner l'apparence de l'argent honnête
et donc il y a tout un processus à
travers les banques à travers des
sociétés écran pour rendre cet argent
honnête ce qui fait qu'après vous
trouver des grandes sociétés qui sont
des sociétés d'immobilier des banques
qui sont tenu en fait par des capit plôt
mafieux mais on ne le sait pas parce que
cet argent a été blanchi ce qui fait que
dans le fond vous avez un pouvoir du
crime même sur l'économie en apparence
légal pas seulement le souteneur
traditionnel non des grandes boîtes qui
ont pignon sur rue et derrière les
capitaux sont mec avec des attach des
bureaux et celui qu'on a arrêté je
raconte ça dans le le bouquin la grande
histoire du blanchiment en Europe le
type qui était chargé de gérer tous les
comptes pour blanchir l'argent de la
drogue du cartel de Cali sortez d'arvard
et il y a plutôt intérêt aujourd'hui
voilà quand vous voulez utiliser les
mécanismes financiers qui sont
compliqués donc c'est pas le petit
malfra habituel c'est effectivement le
malfra sorti des grandes écoles et qui
travaille à la City de Londres alors
vous parlez des paradis fiscaux vous
dites que oui évidemment quand on pense
à paradis fiscal on s'imagine que c'est
un coin super sympa avec des lagons une
mer bleue des petites banques comme ça
c'est très sympathique vous dites que
malheureusement c'est pas ça alors il y
a eu quelques avancées il y a eu Monaco
quand même où il y a eu quand même des
avancées et puis à l'époque de Dominique
stroscan en 99 il y a eu Saint-Martin et
saint-bartelémi où là-bas personne paye
d'impôt enfin c'est vraiment la for
d'emploi du territoire français hein et
donc là-bas Dominque strosc en 1999
avait tenté de mettre les choses un peu
d'AP plom et depuis que rafarin est venu
il a redonné l'indépendance fiscale à
ces deux îles ce qui fait qu'on repart
en arrière c'est ce que vous dites le le
le bouquin vient un peu de ça parce que
moi j'étais président de cette mission
qui était unique qui a duré 3 ans ça a
été la plus longue mission parlementaire
de la 5e République long on a pu très
modestement hein parce que ces sujets
avancent pas mais on a pu faire bouger
quelques lignes vous avez parlé de
Monaco on est allé lstein au Luxembourg
ça a fait des grands scandales les
incidents diplomatiques mais au bout du
bout ça bougé un peu alors on a
l'indépendance fiscale de saint-barelemi
mais tous les sujets qui préoccupent les
gens qui nous écoutent la Maré noire le
prestige met à l'Europe les 2000
chômeurs de et on voit rafarin qui dit
patron voyou mais le patron voyou il est
dans un petit canton de Suisse on est
àsou et rien ne change les les grandes
faillites que l'on voit Enron ou
récemment en Italie oui par c'est
l'utilisation massive chaque fois des
mêmes procédés société cran euh fiduci
ça passe toujours par la Suisse comme la
corruption politique d'ailleurs toutes
les histoires qu'on suit et celles qui
sont en train de ressortir avec les
frégates de taiïwan vous retrouvez les
mêmes acteurs c'est quand même quelque
chose alors je vou dire c'est que en
fait ce que vou dire c'est que les
coupables sont identifiés et qu'il y a
pas de volonté politique réelle pour les
poursuiv parce que vous reprochez aussi
à rafarin par exemple le projet
d'amnistie fiscale sur les capitaux
tricolores évaporés à l'étranger vous
dites là si l'état accepte que ses
capitaux reviennent en France l'État
devient de facto lui-même un
blanchisseur vous allez instituer
Monsieur Sarkozy en grand blanchisseur
national et tous les mafieux ça a été le
cas en Italie d'ailleursuscon faitir
amener leur argent pendant que vous
continuez de demander quand même à ceux
qui gagnent 1500 € par mois par exemple
célibataire de payer leurs impôts on est
dans une aberration politique donc je
pense j'espère que ça ne se fera pas
mais alors là ce serait vraiment rupture
de tout sens commun votre livre est très
complet on voit que ce problème des des
capitaux mobiles issu du crime bah
finalement ça favorise les les crises
financières parce que c'est des ils ont
des comportements un petit peu ératique
vous parlez de la mondialisation
criminelle face à laquelle la communauté
internationale est impuissante vous
dites qu'il faudra qu'on qu'on baptise
dans les années qui viennent un ordre
public mondial vous dites en fait que le
capitalisme est malade et que tout ça
est intrinsèque au capitalisme et c'est
pour ça qu'on est un peu inquiet euh sur
la façon de se sortir de cette situation
parce que s'il faut abolir le
capitalisme pour abolir le blanchiment
c'est pas de malveille quand même hein
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire on a fait un
grand désordre grand désordre mondial
c'est la même chose qui existait dans
nos pays au début du 19e siècle quand on
fait la révolution industrielle vous
savez pas de loi sociale les gosses
travaillent 16 he vous avez même pas le
suffrage universel et on va construire
dans le cadre de l'État naation pour
essayer quand même de faire que ce soit
pas simplement les intérêts financiers
qui dominent al c'est des combats c'est
1830 1848 on va construire
progressivement par le combat ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui d'un mot vilain mais
les régulations pour essayer de nous
donner face aux intérêts de l'argent des
droits et des moyens d'intervenir bon
ben c'est ce qu'il faut reconstruire
aujourd'hui il faut pas être nostalgique
de la nation on va pas y revenir il faut
construire avec l'Europe et dans le
cadre multilatéral ce qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui un ordre public mondial je
pense qu'on est dans un désordre public
mondial qui fait d'ailleurs très peur à
nos concitoy vous répondz pas à ma
question si si pour supprimer le
blanchiment il faut détruire le
capitalisme c'est pas de mal àveilleand
je n'ai pas dit alors je vous réponds je
ne pense pas du tout qu'il faille
détruire le capitalisme je pense qu'il
faut lui donner des règles et
qu'aujourd'hui la première question
c'est de lui donner des règles parce
qu'il n'en a pas vous êtes utopiste sans
doute un petit peu on va faire une
interview utopie
alors
est-ce que vous croyez encore que
l'argent peut ne pas contrôler le monde
oui je pense que c'est un combat qu'il
faut mener et qu' a pas on est partagé
est-ce que vous croyez encore que le
libéralisme n'est pas la seule option
possible le libéralisme politique de la
Révolution française c'est-à-dire la
liberté individuelle c'est mon option
l'ultralibéralisme de Berlusconi non et
je pense que on s'en détournera bientôt
ça a 20 ans dans le fond pas plus ouais
vous croyez encore au socialisme oui je
crois au socialisme ouais vous croyez
encore en françois
Hollande bien sûr vous croyez encore
qu'un jour le PS aura un programme
original et novateur mais on va s'y
mettre bientôt ah faudrait vous y mettre
là quand même il y a urgence très
honnête vous croyez encore que si tous
les gars du monde vlaiss donner la main
bah je pense vous m'avez parlé tout à
l'heure des politiques parce que c'est
votre style je le comprends moi ce qui
m'a le plus choqué je vais vous le dire
c'est que dans ce combat les citoyens
s'en foutent totalement ouais que il y a
un petit arabe au coin de la rue où la
prostituée roumaine elle gêne le mafieux
derrière ne gêne pas tout ce qui se
cache derrière et qui est absolument
colossal personne n'en parle et quand on
a mené ce combat moi j'ai vu bondane au
politique autant que vous voulez mais
bon édane aussi aux citoyens et donc on
se donne la main c'est tout le monde se
bouge est-ce que vous voyez encore en la
France black blanc beur
B bien entendu puis c'est pas en ce CZ
encore l'intégration vous pensez pas
qu'on est passé du côté maintenant du
communautarisme définitivement non je
pense que c'est c'est une grande bagarre
qu'on a au quotidien mais je pense pas
que ce soit le fond et il y a beaucoup
de gens qui sont mobilisés depuis un ou
de ans on a des dérapages absolument
inadmissibles et je pense que on y
arrivera croyez encore au retour de
lunette Jospin bah je crois j'observe
ouais vous croyez encore en la paix en
Palestine je pense que c'est un des
sujets sur lesquels vous parliez
d'utopie tout à l'heure il y a des des
dingues qui parlaient de P perpétuel ou
qui parlait d'Union Européenne et on se
moquait d'eux il y a de siècles je pense
que pour les années qui viennent c'est
le grand sujet vous croyez encore à la
France oui je pense qu'on a une crise de
l'esprit public qui est profonde et moi
je suis très attaché à la France pas une
France fermée sur elle-même mais cette
France qui essayer de porter des valeurs
universelles et je pense si on était
sincère dans nos convictions je crois
que c'est un pays qui pourrait faire
plus pour lui-même plus pour les siens
et plus pour les autres
aussi noir du
blanchim che HCH littérature m
monieurs alors vous parlez un petit peu
dans motif du financement des partis
alors Michel Mouillot était là la
semaine dernière il est reparti avec une
mallette il est reparti avec une
mallette que Laurent lui a gentiment
donné al il nous expliquit que depuis
1990 finalement rien n'avait changé
finalement aujourd'hui les partis
politiques touchaient 150 millions
d'euros par an qui se partageent à
l'aigrement mais que il continuait quand
même à à tirer du pognon aux entreprises
en prendre un peu partout d'une certaine
façon son excuse c'était d'expliquer
quand on est en bas on peut pas financer
sa propre campagne politique alors dans
la loi dont on a parlé moi j'ai fait
plusieurs campagnes électorales c'est
les impôts collectifs qui payent les
campagnes politiques même des
conseillers généraux je vous donne un
exemple pour que les gens comprennent
vous avez le droit à 50000 € près de
60000 pour une campagne législative et
on vous en remboursera l'État le préfet
de votre région 25000 donc on calcule
tous notre campagne à 25000 € pour pas
avoir à taper la grand-mère ou taper
comme vous le dites l'entreprise du coin
et ça fait des années que ça dure donc
moi j'ai fait des campagnes électorales
payer sur fond public où il y a une
vraie moralisation parce que vous n'avez
rien à demander et donc ce qu'il a dit
la semaine dernière est totalement faux
comment tu le trouves il est pas mal non
ah non bien bien à moi bien non moi j'ai
eu un petit un petit pépin au début et
puis après ça a été très bien non au
début non le petit pépin c'était tu as
raté ton entrée pour nous mais
après apr c'estàd que non au début
c'était bon le combat contre les mafieux
honnêtement c'était pas c'était pas
grave pour moi c'est bizarre moi je suis
un monstre je suis un monstre ça me gêne
pas non mais ça me gêne pas moi ce qui
me gène c'est le tout d'un coup c'est
quand on on on tape dans les caisses de
du citoyen ça ça me gêne moi le le
combat contre le mafieux c'est un combat
de de flic de police enfin je veux dire
c'est pas voyez et et tout d'un coup
donc le côté mafieux le côté voyou le
côté blanchiment tout ça je me dis bah
après tout ce sont des voyou quoi depuis
l'alcool interdit tout ça c'est c'est
pas grave ce sont des voyou non ce qui
ce qui est gênant c'est que tout d'un
coup il y a des gens pour qui on vote et
qui et qui ont cette confiance c'est
ceuxl faut les combattre quoi plus que
les mafieux quoi les mafieux c'est un
combat normal quoi ceci étant dit
honnêtement vous aujourd'hui en Europe
se développe on vient de voter pour les
européennes le trafic d'organ c'est
qu'il y a des types qui vendent leur Rin
ou leur cornet pour 500 € pour qu'on les
vende dans nos cliniques à 100000 € et
il y a des types qui font donc vous
voyez entre 1500 et 100000 de l'argent
avec ça vous vous dites je m'en fous
c'est normal ah non j'ai pas dit je m'en
fous c'est normal le Comat sur la police
et la justice exist dans notre pays
aujourd'hui le fait que la coopération
judiciaire et policière marche pas en
Europe c'est quand même votre affaire
ouais mais enfin bon taper dans les
caisses au niveau municipal ça ça me
gène vraiment c'est un vrai débat l' de
de dire effectivement qu'on est contre
le trafic d'organe je trouve ça
tellement normal enfin je veux dire
c'est vrai c'est vrai qu' une espèce de
résignation devant ces activités de de
blanchiment parce que beaucoup de gens
comme dit Patrick pensent que c'est
l'affaire de la police et que c'est pas
leur affaire alors qu'un mec qui vole
dans la caisse d'une mairie on pense que
c'est plus notre affaire ça ça vous ça
vous fait quoi ce genre de discussion ça
j'ai pas tout imprimé la politique là ça
vous fatigue non sérieusement ça vous
fatigue non c'est c'est enfin il y a
beaucoup de choses j'ai du mal à suivre
tout ce que vous dites il y a beaucoup
d'affaires enfin la plupart d'ailleurs
que j'ai absolument pas suivi et puis je
Cais qu'on se revoit peut-être mais je
sais pas parce que gar Vincent là un mec
c'est
dur tout l'URE elle l'adore tu as vu le
seul qui trouve grâce à ses yeux à part
Joh de un mec un peu dans le CRE de la
vague en ce moment mais il a un peu
grossi en ce moment non non ENF c'est ça
c'est certainement assez irresponsable
de parler comme ça j'ai j'ai jamais voté
et je je j'arrive pas j'arrive pas à
vous écouter c'est le costume qui passe
pas c'est quoi Plô éc là une peti Mar et
tout je regardis ça vous parlez beaucoup
avec vos mains je décroche quoi j'y
arrive pas il y a une fréquence sur
laquelle vous vous branchez même si vous
dites des choses intéressantes on sent
un rondronnement très très bien étudié
travaillé donc on
décroche après ça revient et après ça
revient ça plus clair non c'était clair
excusez-moi je on était très d'accord
avec lui simplement c'était pour
expliquer le fait qu' décre je parlais
pas de vous et de de ce que vous venez
de dire qui était c'était chargé il y
avait beaucoup de choses quoi mais
c'était clair c'est en règle générale
c'est toujours on va faire bien on va
faire mieux on va aider les un on va
aider les autres et il y a toujours que
des histoires de fric il y a toujours
que des histoires de guerre toujours
c'est c'est
c'est tu es hermétique à ça tu es
imperméable à ça
toi j'ai j'ai pas le temps voilà j'ai
pas le temps B je sais pas mais c'est
vrai que c'est des discours qui qui sont
quand même assez encourageant la volonté
d'agir et cetera ça nous saoule de
belles paroles on est ivre comme ça on
est grisé par par ce rite mais par cette
volonté je pense sincère de bien faire
politiquement mais moi j'ai peur demain
de me réveiller avec la gueule de bois
quoi je donn une carte de on s'em branle
c'est la
dernière vcent payant les milliards
noirs du blan
ciment
je vous laisser aller vous coucher
Vanessa bien
cont Vincent maintenant
bon à bientôt alors vous revenez tous
les deux pour la sortie du film de Serge
Friedman mon
ange
salut
bientô 22 décembre
tué mon fils est né le 22 décembre
cétait vu pour ton anniversaire la
naissance de mon
fils
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était pas brillant maison cé la
véritéens et
[Musique]
maintenant voici Tony Marchall et
jean-pa
gtier
[Musique]
oh jeir March
jeanper bonsoir Tony bonsoir Jean-Paul
bonsoir alors Tony oui vous êtes une
enfant de la balle hein puisque vous
êtes la fille de Bill Marchall acteur
réalisateur américain le mari de Michel
Morgan à une époque et donc le le le
grand-père de la fameuse Sarah Marchall
et oui absolument absolument vous êtes
parente un petit peu avec Sarah Marchall
c'est ma nièce c'est votre nièce voilà
mais je la connais très peu mais on
s'est vu il y a assez longtemps avant
qu'elle épouse j'ai oublié son nom
Alexandre Anthony Alexandre Anthony
voilà ah ils font un beau coup tous les
deux hein mais il paraît donc voà vous
êtes la fille donc de Bill Marchall et
de Micheline prell évidemment cette
grande actrice qu'on qu'on adore tous
Micheline pr voilà et quand vous étiez
enfant vous dormiez dans une chambre qui
joutait la salle de projection du studio
des des Ursulines alors quand vous étiez
toute petite vous entendiez le son et
puis ensuite vous êtes devenu copine
avec l'ouvreuse et puis elle vous
laissait rentrer dans la salle du studio
des ursilines comme ça vous avez vu très
jeune des films de Godard de Bergman les
Einstein enfin vraiment vous avez une
formation très précoce j'avais le la la
cabine du projectionniste était à peu
près à on était c'est par par une cour
de 3 m et donc l'été particulièrement il
allait fumer une clope sur le l'escalier
en métal et donc il ouvrait la porte de
la cabine et j'ai donc j'ai connu les
films en entier par le son je connais
Alexandr nievski pratiquement
phonétiquement et cetera voilà alors
vous avez fait plein de films vous à
votre tour ensuite le plus connu disons
c'est Vénus Beauté institut hein qui a
été nominé SEP fois au César qui en a
décroché quatre César du meilleur film
du meilleur scénario de la meilleure
réalisatrice et meilleur espoir féminin
pour la fameuse Audrey totou qui depuis
a fait qu'estce qu'elle
fait toou non peut-être que tu la
connais mieux sous le nom de
améli Catherine qui dit am Poulin
j'adore bien et votre dernier film
cétait France boutique dont judith godr
est venu parler ici cet hiver voilà
alors Jean-Paul Gautier vous en plus des
activités qui portent votre nom on va
pas toutes les énumérer parce que ça
commence à faire pas mal vous avez signé
en mars dernier votre première
collection pour Hermes où vous revisitez
les grands classiques de la maison dans
un esprit voilà modernisé Gautier voilà
ludique vous continuez à travailler pour
le cinéma et le le spectacle vous êtes
occupé de de Peter greenowway de carot
et Jeunet de Besson
d'Almodovar de Madonna d'ivette Horner
de Johnny ALID et de Sylvie vtan alors
j'ai lu dans une interview j'ai lu dans
une interview récemment Sylvie vtan les
autres ils étaient cont mais elle elle a
pas l'air très contente dans son bouquin
et ceera donc on a lu le bouquin de
Sylvie Vartan et à aucun moment elle se
plaint de vous alors la seule chose qui
aurait pu arriver c'est qu'elle oublie
de parler de vous mais elle dit pas de
mal de vous dans son bouquin mais alors
je sais pas je me demande je me demande
si en fin de compte j'ai pas lu un autre
livre ouais parce que je sais pas il y
en a pas deux sur Sylv bartan un
celui-là il est écrit par elle dans
celui qui est écrit par elle elle ne
parle pas de vous du tout alors ça doit
être l'autre écrit par un journaliste ou
je sais pas c'est celui-là que j'ai lu
et je croyais que c'était celui où il y
a une vilaine couverture pas très jolie
couverture voilà c'est pas elle on a
vraiment cherché elle dit rien contre
vous elle elle et simplement de parler
de vous c'est vrai ou oui bah quand même
alors
[Musique]
donc alors justement si vous deviez
relooker Vincent payon quand même voilà
un homme politique qui qui est plutôt
beau gosse faut dire les choses hein qui
qui est intelligent travailleur tout
mais au niveau du look est-ce que vous
pensez qu'il doit rester comme ça pour
pour faire sérieux pour faire homme
politique la cravate le costume ça très
honnête ça me fascine pas tellement le
fait d'habiller
comment les politiciens parce que je
trouve que bon ils ont certaines règles
à appliquer et tout bon ben voilà délire
quoi les anim hyper classique c'est le
mieux non pour eu habiller un animateur
télé c'est vous entrer Jean-Paul moi par
exemple pour la rentrée qu'est-ce que
vous me conseilleriez parce que ça fait
quand même 18 ans que je suis habillé
comme ça va bien vous bien je trouve
c'est comme une espèce d'image de
marqueay alors jean-pul goer est-ce que
vous faites des fautes de goût vous oh
sûrement plein ouais vousê déjà retrouvé
en train de faire des courses le
dimanche matin avec un surv et des
mocassin ça vous est arrivé
ce genre de qui peut devenir bien ceci
dit mais qui peut devenir bien ça dépend
comme tout est fait de la façon dont
c'est fait quoi il y a des choses qui
sont à une époque horrible tout ce qu'il
faut pas faire et puis après qu'il au
contraire qu'on trouve on passe pas un
stade différent et on trouve ça plutôt
rigolo et bien vous êtes déjà retrouvé
en Marcelle devant un match de foot par
exemple ben non je regarde pas les match
de foot alors déjà à l'église en mini
jupe avec des lunettes no c'est jamais
allé par exemple je porte pas de mini
jupe le kilte je le porte de temps à Ha
ouais à
l'église demain vous savez ce qu'il y a
demain après-midi sur France 5 euh
absolument ah absolument c'est pas un
match de foot donc non à 15h30 sur
France 5 il y a un documentaire de Tony
Marchall sur Jean-Paul Gautier voilà oui
alors au début quand on vous a dit de
faire un documentaire vous vous êtes dit
ou là là jamais fait de documentaire
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette histoire
et puis euh vous pareil vous dites ou là
là je vais pas avoir une équipe sur le
dos pendant 5 mois moi donc au départ
c'était pas c'était pas évident je
savais pas encore que c allait être Tony
Marchall après quand j'ai su que c'était
elle qui vous a réuni c'est un film un
film sur la mode un film des années 50
un film de jacqu Becker qui s'appelle
Falbala dont l'héroïne est votre maman
Micheline prell il se trouve que
Micheline prell vous vous l'adorez
d'ailleurs vous l'avez habillé pour pour
pour les Césars on voit ça à la fin du
du documentaire d'ailleurs c'est votre
star mais oui tout à fait puisque bon
moi je suis un enfant de la télé on va
dire donc j'ai j'ai j'ai regardais la
télé tout gamin et je me souviens qu'à
un moment j'avais vu une émission des
Folies Bergères sur les Folies Bergères
don je voulais habiller je voulais faire
des costumes pour les Folies Bergères ça
commençait comme ça et puis après j'ai
vu Falbala et là c'était le coup de foot
total je me suis dit non c'est la mode
ça je devais avoir je sais pas 12 ans 10
12 ans c'est quand même probablement le
seul film qui raconte le processus d'une
collection de haute couture du début
jusqu'à la fin c'est qu'après ça c'était
la vérité c'était ma bible en quelque
sorte de Jac Becker très beau film alors
le documentaire s'appelle les falbalas
de Jean-Paul gotier
pour rien donc vous parlez de votre vie
professionnelle et puis de votre vie
privée alors sur le plan professionnel
on apprend que vous dessinez 12
collections par an donc vous êtes
toujours dans l'urgence quoi c'est ouais
ou ouais c'est un petit peu c'est ça le
rythme de la mode c'est c'est assez
étonnant en plus on peut faire quelque
fois des des collections qui sont de
plusieurs saisons en même temps enfin là
je suis à la fois sur l'été l'hiver
enfin alors on découvre aussi dans ce
documentaire que vous laissez appeler
monsieur comme Coco Chanel se faisait
appeler mademoiselle jusqu'à présent on
me disait Jean-Paul ou bon d'abord parce
qu'on était pas nombreux et puis j'ai
commencé par à faire du prê à porter
donc c'était pas la même façon la même
le même vocabulaire on va dire que dans
la couture où j'ai commencé étant
assistant mais là quand comme j'ai pris
certaines personnes certaines comment
mettons la première d'atelier qui venait
de la couture elle elle avait l'habitude
de dire monsieur parce qu'elle
travaillait avec Monsieur janchi donc ça
a été monsieur donc je me suis retrouvé
d'un seul coup paf avec Monsieur ouais
ça fait un peu Chanel quoi non sauf que
c'était mademoiselle donc elle m'a pas
dit mademoiselle ça murait peut-être un
peu plus étonné si m'av dit mademoiselle
je peut-être mieux oui alors vous parlez
de votre vie privée aussi d' de façon
assez franche je trouve
hein Fran non c'est vrai c'est assez
ouais ouais ouais en tous les cas ce
documentaire vous avez évité une
psychanalyse sûrement mais oui c'est ça
ce que je disais en fin de compte j'ai
je merci Tony je crois qu'elle a
été c'est tout à fait ça bien alors tous
les deux vous allez regarder la caméra
où il y a le rouge et vous allez dire en
même temps si vous le dites pas en même
temps ça marchera pas je pas être
synchro attention faut être synchro je
vais vous donner un top ouais vous dites
magnit Serge
1 2 3 magnet Serge
Serge non non c'est tout le temp alors
ser c'est quoi cette histoire enfin tu
me pourris avec tous les invités
attention non mais même c'était bien 1 2
3 magn
atttion 1 2 3 Magneto Serge mais mais
regardez je sais pas qui est-ce qui me
le coupe mais je suis toujours pareil
moi ma poitrine c'est toujours une
espèce de goutte comme ça qui remonte en
c'est toujours pareil alors que vous
vous souvenez ici ça doit être arrondi
et tout je ve dire je sais pas qui
est-ce qui prend ce patronage là mais à
chaque fois c'est la même forme j'ai pas
la forme du sein puisque j'avais dit que
je voulais av plus de bombé j'ai déjà
fait la rectification moi-même j'ai
encore une forme en arrondi comme ça en
goutte qui qui
remonte c'est pareil regardez mon profil
toujours pareil c'est comme l'autre fois
et regardez là j'ai une espèce de
d'angle d'angle qui qui correspond à
quoi cet angle là j'ai jamais un un
front aussi anguleux vous voyez ce que
je veux dire c'est comme je sais pas
c'est pas respecté du tout le dessin il
y a rien de bon tout est il faut penser
une en manchure bon la Manche admettons
voilà sans sans ça la faire qu'elle
n'existe pas et après il faut surtout ce
morceau-l ce morceau-là qui doit être
d'un morceau d'un seul morceau et voir
là où il arrive pour me faire mon profil
regardez et il doit tenir comme ça voilà
France 5 demain à 15h30 les falbalad de
Jean-Paul gutier un documentaire de Tony
Marchall voilà quel boulot quand même
non oh là là Tony alors qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez vous l'avez eu là pendant
5 mois ah ben c'est absolument étonnant
c'està-dire que je crois qu'il part de
il a un espèce de on va dire quoi un
espèce de petit cimetière de bout
VI San des tas de trucs comme ça et
alors il va derrière il tripote des tas
de morceaux comme ça il tripote
énormément il a absolument besoin de ça
il a pas de dessin il a vaguement des
trucs collés au mur qu'il regarde pas
souvent et puis il tripote il tripote il
tripote ce qui a plus àan d'ailleurs et
puis après il commence à avoir une toile
et puis voilà il y a des choses on le
voit dans le documentaire il y a des
moments où ça rate complètement où il
sait pas et cetera et puis tout d'un
coup ça vient et là c'est vraiment
intéressant parce que on voit qu'est-ce
que c'est qu'un moment où o tout d'un
coup là ouais parce que Jean-Paul il ne
crée le vêtement que par la parole il
n'arrête pas de parler alors il dit tout
le temps tout le temps alors là le tissu
ça fait si ça fait ça puis au bout d'un
moment il arrête de dire le tissu il
commence à dire alors là je vais avoir
ça un peu plus serré dites donc là je
cloque et puis alors là je Godde donc je
va alors il faut il faut je ne suis pas
doublé et il se met Absolum à la place
du vêtement et à partir de là le
discours se structure alors qu'avant
devient le vêtement il devient le
vêtement et c'est très frappant ouis et
ça et après il perfectionne il est
singlis quoi mais bien saint
TR alors il y a un autre événement
concernant JeanPaul Gautier c'est
l'exposition pain couture bail Jean-Paul
Gautier à la Fondation quartier pour
l'art contemporain alors là il a
transformé 1000 m² en boulangerie et
vous faites des robes en pain h vous
allez regarder votre caméra on va
recommencer l'expérience à 3 vous dire
mag avec vcent avec Vincent allez
Vincent avec Vincent avec Vincent
attention 1 2 3 mageto Serge moiselle
sacré
[Musique]
français vous dansez mademoiselle sacré
français sacré
[Musique]
fr
r voilà Jean-Paul Gautier donc c la
Fondation quartier pour l'art
contemporain alors jean-paer vous avez
inventé la la jupe pour homme et
dernièrement le maquillage pour
homme testé par Vincent prez José Garcia
David bécan non il y a des des choses
c'est à la fois comment à la fois
tonifiant enfin c'est des toniques et
puis aussi des choses par exemple pour
les lèvres pour ce protéger les lèvres
mais en même temps colorer un peu si on
veut mais ça peut être aussi très neutre
à la base et aussi pour je sais pas les
sourcils comme comme le col destoitto RG
l'entour des yeux bon donc c'est des
choses quand
même on peut très bien les mettre sans
avoir l'air maquillé il y a une g pour
hom politique oui je crois que neutre
ouis est neutre et alors on se le passe
avec un blér c'est ça qui est rigol ou
is en reprenant les gestes par exemple
même pour l'œil c'est comme un stylo un
stylo parce que c'est un geste que l'
conna plus voilà voilà quel peut-être
l'avenir de la mode on faire une
interview à la
[Musique]
mode est-ce que vous pensez qu'un jour
pourrait être à la mode les espaderill
montantes ah oui tout à
fait les pantalons dans les
chaussettes totalement c'est pas beau
quand même hein les pantalons chbert
Wilson tout va à lombert Wilson même son
nom non mais sérieux il mettrait le
pantalon dans les chaussettes il serait
beauos les soutiensgorges pour H t
Wilson euh à mon avis ça non mais
sérieux en plus ça lu ri non mais c'est
c'est pas de la vanne ou c'est vrai
c'est que tout
vainjustice c'est comme ça il y a des
genss élgant vous chquerit pas le
soutien gorge pour hom mais il peut
avoir des des des des forme si sil
dessine la morphologie masculine
peut-être musclée mais oui à partir du
moment où il y a un rapport c'est pas
comme une prothèse quoi pour pourrait
ressembl une femme voilà les strings
kangouroust Wilson il le défendrait bien
peut-être c'est déjà la mode il y en a
certains qui le les bottes en PET de
[__] déjà faut faire une botte dans une
pet de [__] c'est dire enfin je veux
dire faut faut avoir la [__]
en sinon c'est pas deur quoi si c'est
une pièce c'est joli quand même hein ça
vous semble possible pourquoi pas non il
y a plein de choses qui sont faites
comme ça il y a des il y a des il y a
des dépôts de poissons et tout qui sont
incroyables qu'on connait pas enfin il y
a plein de choses qui sont faites donc
la peau de bit peut en effet être un
élément pourquoi pas peut-être qu'on
fera pas merci c'est pourquoi oh c'est
sorti carte de mes couilles c'est du
page voilà Jean-Paul Gautier il y a
aussi un album édité par la Fondation
quartier sur P couture by Jean-Paul
Gautier bien alors tu vas aller te
coucher toi maintenant ouais va te
coucher
dégage dans
l'Américain de
Pat et maintenant qu'est-ce qu'il m'a
dit aujourd'hui je suis amoureux de ma
FEM c'est
FA au premier jour je suis amoureux de
[Applaudissements]
Mao ilvant àal
voilà alors il a déjà une carte lui il a
une carte de quoi carte de beau gosse ah
ouais une carte de beau gosse voilà très
bien ça
commence j'en peux plus d'avoir des
cartes de ça va ça va bien donc après ma
femme est une actrice dont nous avons
dit ici le plus grand bien vous sortez
Ivan Atal le 25 août votre 2uxè film il
se marièrent et eu beaucoup d'enfants
avec Charlotte ginzebourg Emmanuel
Seigner Alain Chabat Alain Cohen le
petit garçon du vieil homme et l'enfant
qui revient Johnny deppp qui revient
aussi parce qu'il était dans le creux de
la vague ouais c'est ce qu'on disait à
Vanessa tout à l'heure il a pris du B il
a grossi he il est il devrait surveiller
le Johnny Depp Anou Kem Claude Berry et
vous voilà alors le pitch il y a un
pitch normal qui serait c'est une
comédie sur la difficulté de rester en
couple et puis à mon pit à moi c'est le
mariage c'est l'enfer le célibat c'est
l'enfer l'adultère c'est l'enfer et
c'est vrai VO ça plombe bien tout de
suite et quand tu vois le film tu sors
de là [__] un film non c'est pas
[__] tu dises que c'est une comédie
derrière tout est grave tout est
difficile non mais ceci dit c'est un peu
l'idée l'idée c'était de le traiter
légèrement mais c'est vrai que ça
raconte ça ça raconte que c'est quand
mêmeile au dép c'est pas gay du tout
l'histoire alors vous le traitez très
bien et d'une façon très sympathique
mais quand même tout est l'Enfer quand
tu vois ce film si tu veux c'est qu'
chaba il est marié avec Emmanuel
saignier qui le martyrise il y a Cohen
lui alors lui c'est le célibataire que
tard mais toute façon ça se termine très
mal pour lui il est planté à la fin et
puis av vous alors c'est extraordinaire
c'est extraordinaire et ça ça m'a
beaucoup touché dans le film c'est que
donc notre ami Yvan trompe Charlotte
ginbourg et alors ils ont un truc avec
Charlotte ginsbourg c'est qu'ils aiment
bien s'asperger avec de l'eau et à un
moment vous aspergez la maîtresse et la
maîtresse n'apprécie pas et là on voit
on comprend c'est vachement subtile on
comprend qu'à ce
vous dites je préfère ma femme ça c'est
très
fort
a
[Applaudissements]
bien ça c'est pour CELI
qui
ça en cou ça cou
c'est c'est l'inconvéent d'ê pass à côté
de
Laurent la mauvaise place la mauaise
place c'est Mo c'est MOS s jeux dire
parti pour
parti
OK et voilà et voilà donc voilà donc
tout le mond
a pas mal
bien voilà donc tout le monde a bien
compris dernière je crois que c'est la
dernière et vous aussi chez vous
n'hésitez
pas on est au cœur du film vivant à T
qu' a cette scène magnifique bien cette
scène magnifique sur laeule exactement
comme ça on est exactement dans le film
divant faitesle à la maison che vous il
a quand même un truc juste il est tout
sec quoi non non regarde regarde regarde
Tony couvert
d'eau donc malheureusement avec la
maîtresse ça ne marche pas et là d'un
seul coup on sent bien Ivan
[Musique]
charot petit
papavant ce que vous allez faire vous
regarder la caméra où il y a le rouge et
vous allez dire magnéerge et pant ce
temp on va se sécher la rou C oui avec
les micros voilà il se marie et ilre
beaucoup d'enfants IV avec Charlotte
gbourg Alain Chab al cor Ivan
Emmanuel
voilà ça
va sorti le 25 août et on sent vraiment
en voyant ce film que vous êtes un fou
de cinéma il y a un bonheur de filmer il
y a une jubilation à filmer il y a des
moments vous éclatez il y a un côté
lelouge dans le plaisir qu'il avait à
filmer il y a 30 ans quoi on sent que ça
vous plaît quoi ça vous aimez le cinéma
vraimentou c'est pour ça que aussi j'ai
eu envie de passer derrière après 10 ans
devant c'est parce que j'aime ça et que
si je pouvais même aller sur un film et
faire juste le casting si je pouvais je
sais pas quoi ENF quand on est passionné
de cinéma on a sent vous êtes un fou de
cinéma vraiment il y a une scène où ils
sont avec Shaba et Alain Cohen tous les
trois où chaba veut pas remonter chez
lui parce qu'Emmanuel seier lui casse
vraiment les couilles et il aimerait que
ses copains restent avec lui et les
autres veulent se barrer parce qu'ils en
ont r le bol et c'est magnifique quoi ça
n'en finit plus c'est dans le hall d'un
immeuble un peu un peu chip comme ça
quoi les trois mecs vendent des bagnoles
enfin c'est pas ils vendent des bagnoles
ils vivent leur vie chacun avec leurs
femmes leurs enfants et et tous on ont
un peu ralcul les deux les deux mariés
envie la vie du célibataire le
célibataire envie la vie des mariés
puisque lui-même se fait un peu chier
dans la vie la solitude c'est presque
pire que tout se lever se coucher tout
seul et on suit ces trois mecs pendant
un long moment avant de bifurquer au
détour d'une allée chez Virgin quand
Charlotte croise un beau garçon c'est
plutôt une belle scène il y a aucun mot
qui est dit tous les deux écoutent le
même disque rondpoint chez Virg comme on
peut écouter de la musique et puis tous
les deux écoutent le même disque et puis
il se passe des choses entre eux sans
qu'il ait besoin de dire quoi que ce
soit ce qui très bien aussi dans votre
film c'est qu'il y a des séquences
onirriques comme ça on sait pas si c'est
des des des des flash forward ou si
c'est des séquences imaginaires enfin il
y a un peu de tout il y a aussi ça c'est
une séquence réelle d'ailleurs elle
rentre à la maison elle a acheté le
disque et puis elle fait la cuisine elle
écoute ce disque on sent bien qu'elle
est qu'elle est ailleurs il y a d'autres
séquences qui sont imaginaires il y a un
moment elle est agent immobilier char
unlotte elle fait visiter un appartement
puis tout d'un coup ou comme ça au
milieu de la visite elle elle elle elle
se rend compte en faisant visiter
l'appartement de de ce que pourrait être
la vie des autres et ce que pourrait
être sa vie et elle s'imagine la vie
sans lui à ce moment-là vraiment on part
avec elle dans son imaginaire elle
s'imagine la vie sans son mari et elle
se rend compte que ça c'est vient lui
dit les enfants c'est toi qui les prends
ça c'est une scène totalement imaginaire
il y a un mélange de scène réel de scène
imaginaire c'est assez c'est assez bien
foutu vous êtes doué B merci beaucoup
vraiment vous avez une bonne pression là
pr vous l' fait un peu dans votre coin
en vous disant bon c'est pas grave
deè film parce que le prier on
absolument rien à perdre et puis quand
le premier a marché alors on espère que
le deuxè vous donnera la possibilité de
faire le 3è enfin vous êtes inquiet
là ou je suis inqui le 24 août vous SZ 2
le 24 non mais je vaisre inquié tout
l'été dit je vais tourner un film pour
me que ça a bien marché le le le premier
là ma femme est une actrice bien très
bien marché il a un remake qui été fait
non il y a un remake qui a pas été fait
et heureusement parce que c'est
probablement Steven Spielberg qui va le
faire
voilà je vois pas qui c'est mais bah
c'est un jeune méoron Américain j'ai eu
l'occasion de le rencontrer à Paris pour
son prochain film et puis quand il m'a
demandé ce que je voulais lui montrer
pour qu'il me voit acteur je lui ai
donné un DVD de mon film et puis il l'a
vu j'étais très étonné qu'il le voit le
soir même il m'a rappelé le soir même
pour me dire qu'il avait adoré et il m'a
demandé si les droit de remake était
pris voilà donc je pense que on va on va
s'arranger ah ouais c'est bienident hein
ouais
alors moi j'ai retrouvé beaucoup
d'interviews ivanal vous disiez toujours
oui mais alors vous n'y couperez pas on
va faire une interview oui
mais alors je vous demande simplement de
finir la phrase j'adore ce film mais
mais je l'adore un point tu peux même
pas t'imaginer je suis peut-être pas le
meilleur réalisateur du monde
mais mais au moins dans mon film j'ai
les meilleurs acteurs du monde je n'ai
rien ement physique
mais mais d'autres non plus
d'ailleurs vous avez quoi l'oreill là je
suis né comme ça ah bon je croyais que
c'était je je dire la vérité je cro que
vous aviez une boucle d'oreill quelqu'un
vous l'avait arraché mais quand je suis
très très en forme je raconte tout un
baratin comme quoi j'ai sauvé une femme
et qu' tu vois mais là je suis né comme
ça là ce soir vous a décidé de dire la
vérité pas vous faire chier je plais
beaucoup aux femmes mais où est le
problème
ouais mais ça agace beaucoup les
c'est vrai que je plais beaucoup aux
hommes mais je suis
marié je suis une star chez les gay mais
mais
pas je n'apprécie pas spécialement les
partous mais mais c'est parce que je
suis très
jaloux l'un dans l'autre j'aime pas les
sandwich Grecs
mais mais dans une
partour je suis pour la PAI dans le
monde mais c'est pas gagné ouais
bien bien c'est vrai mais c'est pas
gagné j'ai jamais pris de drogue mais
mais que j'ai peur des
piures j'ai peur de mourir mais ça je me
soigne
ah j'ai envie de vous Tiry mais mais il
y a un peu trop de
monde
s le
25ur les
bra tuas couch
to il est trop moyen il estop re les de
il est trop
mouillé merci ça
sppelleam
tu sais quoi Laurent j'ai retrouvé mon
team s de l'époque ouais le grand team
le bon client PL le team seat de double
jeu le team Seat d'ardyat et puis on le
voyait plus trop comme ça et là j'ai
retrouver ce soir ce il est parti avec
plein de cartes super client super bon
client
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la
céit mesure
1,80 donc je suis obligé j'ai une petite
j'ai un petit cube là quand les filles
sont grandes je monte dessus quand tu
étais petite ça te posait des problèmes
d'être si grande quand même ouais
j'étais grande très vite donc j'étais
complexé adolesc complexé quand tu donné
la main à un mec dans la rue on aurait
dit que tu étais sa mère c'était petit
copains adolescent c'est sûr maintenant
ça va mieux m les petits copains je
connais ça tout le nom les petits
copains alors Elod dit moi j'y comprends
plus rien les derniers jours dans la
ferme il y en avait que pour vous tous
les résumés quotidiens ne
s'intéressaient qu'à vous Massimo Maxime
m Céline ne tarissez pas d'éloge sur
vous votre sens de
l'organisation le soin vous preniez des
des animaux Massimo a dit en parlant de
vous elle est tellement belle voilà et
pourtant vous êtes la trè derrière HMA
et evangéli alors pourquoi parce que ça
s'était bien passé finalement justement
tout s'est peut-être trop bien passé
ouais et à la fin vous êtes trè ouis
voilà ce qu'on aime bien je pense que
les gens aiment bien aussi les victimes
ou les martyres quelque part et depuis
le début je j'ai je suis rentrée tel que
j'étais j'en sors tel que tel que je
suis je n'ai pas changé j'ai donné le
meilleur dès le départ il y a pas eu
d'évolution en fait je pense ouais c'est
vrai ça tu as suivi un peu non ouais ah
ouais je l'adore goautier dire que la
ferme c'était génial non franchement on
a passé des moments extraordinaires avec
ce channel 99 le matin quand il se
réveillait il il y avait Hilario un jour
il a dit cette émission ça devrait
s'appeler on achève bien les people il
un peu de ça quand Mme gros succès alors
non peut-être vous avez été sanctionné
parce que vous étiez moins présente au
conseil régional si vous croyez que les
Français vous ont sanctionné à cause de
ça non je P parce que la semaine d'avant
je suis restée face à Vincent mcdom donc
je ne pense pas ouais à cause des
déclarations de Madame de fonenet
peut-être ê non non plus je pense pas
les gens ne sont pas idiots ils voient
clair enfin ouais non parce que c'est
vrai que madame de fonené ça pas ménagé
elle dit c'est une ferme d'opérette
idiote et
perverse 15000 € par semaine pour singer
ceux qui travaillent et prennent jamais
de vacan sur plan politique c'est
acceptable la ferme moi j'ai regardé
qu'une fois parce que mes enfants on
regardaient et j'ai découvert ce
personnage que j'ai trouvé merveilleux
qui est le le monsieur dont vous avez
parlé qui est Vincent mcdom qui essayé
des chaussures il avait chez lui
et j'ai trouvé bon après j'ai pas
regardé nous par ailleurs on a on a des
accintances puisque vous savez que je
suis en Picardie et moi j'ai assisté à à
l'installation du conseil
régional sur la ferme j'ai pas regardé
au-delà mais j'ai trouvé ce Vincent
mcdom tout à fait extraordinaire c'est
vrai tu do tricoter une
échar ce qui est assez e Vincent ce qui
est assez extraordinaire quand même
c'est c'est que la France se soit
passionnée pour les amours de Vincent
mcdou avec all mas qu Mme ass assez
moderne quand même ça madame de fontené
a eu un argument assez dur elle dit
qu'on ne me parle pas d'association
pourquoi pas un film porno pour la Croix
Rouge ah c'est pas con ça c'est pas con
non mais comme idée de
film je vois déjà les
brancardia alors
dit que su vous répondez à toutes ces
questions et à d'autres dans un livre
qui paraît chez Michel Laffond qui
s'appelle mes rêves mes passions mes
amours mes espoirs voilà parle tout
parle du conseil régional de de Picardie
dont vous accusez la dictature morale
vous y êtes vous à ce Conseil Régional
de Picardie oui alors moi j'étais assez
jaloux puisque elodie est arrivé dans la
campagne avec Gilles deobien qui était
notre adversaire et je me suis dit ça ça
va être ouais implacable quoi et
finalement je la remercie plutôt vu le
résultat puisque Gilles deobien n'a
jamais pris un revers électoral aussi
grand que ça et puis après pour les his
bien éclaté en attendant
peut-être tuta moi moi j'étais vous
pensez que elodie est pour quelque chose
dans l'échec de Robien passer de l'un à
l'autre bah attendeztienne Moujotte a
mis un jet privé à sa disposition pour
qu'elle puisse assister au conseil
régionalis pas de raison de refuser
l'opportunité qui est l'émission de
laffireme voilà et pu en plus en plus
honnêtement tout le monde a un boulot au
conseil régional je respecte la
profession de tout conseiller régional
donc c'est pas parce que la mienne est
est médiatisée qu'elle est pas
respectable heinouis c'est ça elle a
découvert comme ça que c'est parfois
difficile d'être élu qu'on est un petit
peuou ça motive d'autant plus en fait
là on assiste à un affrontement gauche
droite de première qualité mesdames
messieurs vous l'imez bien
vous non j'admire j'admire faut qu'elle
continue la politique continue bien et
la sur parce que elle a de la
for on plaisant vous racontez votre
désir de faire de la télé et votre
expérience c'est-à-dire vous êtes parti
à Dubaï je ne savais pas ça vous
racontez ça dans votre bouquin vous
partez à Dubaï pour faire une semaine
d'animation en anglais quotidienne oui
quotidienne pendant le Shopping Festival
en fait de Duba bien ça s bien passé
très bien une expérience très
enrichissante et il y a un émirati qui a
voulu vous épouser h non là j'étais au
départ oui d'ailleurs c'est ça hein il
vous a tout proposé hein bien surû la
Villa les bijoux qu'est-ce qu'il y avait
tout tout et en échange bah de de me
donner à lui ouais et alors ça vous a
pas c'est pas mon concept de l' ni du
mariage non c'est pas une question de
beauté c'est que c'est pas mon concept
du mariage c'est pas ton prix
surtout vous racontez le dit que su dans
ce bouquin vos premières expériences sur
les plateaux de télé quand vous êtes
devenue Miss France alors vous dites
j'étais considéré comme une demeurée
mentale qu'il fallait absolument ménager
par charité chrétienne sur certaines
émissions il y a des préjugés
effectivement il y a des préjugés pas
ici c'est vrai la première émission que
j'ai fait ici j'étais vraiment on t'a
bien traité tu te rappell qu'est-ce
qu'il a dit qu'est-ce qu'il a dit non je
répéterai pas c'est dans sanité mais je
me rappelle très bien vous avez été
moins bien traité ailleurs ce que vous
racontez dans dans votre bouquin vous
êtesit massacré dans une semaine après
mon élection ouais oua c'était terrible
parce qu'effectivement quoi que je dise
quoi que je fasse la réponse était était
la même c'est tu as bien appris ta leçon
de la part de Madame de fontené et je ne
pouvais rien dire j'avais pas la liberté
de parole d'expression je je pouvais pas
donner mes propres réponses c'est elles
étaient pour pour lui elle
par c'est mon plus mauvais souvenir télé
en fait plus mauvais souvenir télé c'est
fel dans de souligné de l'écrire à
l'écran alors vous racontez vos
histoires d'amour aussi alors mais c'est
dans le bouquin j'invente rien donc il y
a David première expérience sexuelle
jeune he à 16 ans ah oui ça s'est passé
où la première fois euh bah à côté de
chez moi mais je veux pas préciser ouais
ouais dans un terrain vague ou non non
non non non non dans une B chambre dans
uneie alors après il y a Laurent le
maître nageur al lu il a 24 ans vous
avez 16 ans vous cou et il vous sauve et
voilà c'est l'année où elodie est élu
Miss
camping et donc évidemment le mec est
maître nageur et les Lumis camping tu
comprends bon ça cré des liens le beau
couple
Abdel ah Abdel beau comme un dieu Abdel
beau comme un dieu hein non il y a eu un
problème avec Abdel c'est quand vous
arrivez à Paris c'est un peu humain
marqu mais c'est en même temps quand
vous arrivez à
Paris vous le voyez moins quoi il y a Mo
ou puis c'est simplement oui la
l'évolution quoi qui est différente on
s'est rencontré très jeune et on a
grandi de manière différente voilà ça
arrive hein voilà et alors Abdel vous le
revoyez quand même de temps en temps
bien sûr à sa cl bien sûr quand vous
dites on fait une dînette c'est une
faute de
frappe sérieux non on est resté très
très proche mais ami ami ou ami
uniquement ami ouais je suis très fierre
d'avoir transform quand REP de mais tu
arrives bien à transformer l'amour en
amitié hein ouais je suis assz doué ce
sont les pires celles-là oui donc on en
arrive à Maxime Maxime Le comicque je
précise pour tout le monde alors là la
pression médiatique a eu raison de votre
couple c'est les pap dit qu'on oui parce
que on nous a piégé ça faisait très peu
de temps qu'on était ensemble donc c'est
vrai quand il y a pas encore la
confiance et la relation qui est sincère
et stable ça détruit un couple je pense
que les médias peuvent détruire un
couple si le le couple n'est pas sûr de
lui en faitou de son amour
réciproque voilà et vous le retrouvez à
la ferme ce Maxime et ben voilà voilà
vous saviez qu'il serait là oui ah et
vous y allez quand même bien sûr parce
que on était resté en bon terme en très
bon terme il vous a redragué à la ferme
non non il y a rien eu non non non non
rien du tout du tout tout avec la ferme
il y a eu des trucs avec quelqu'un je ne
crois pas pas à ma connaissance il y a
des animaux qu'on morfl quand
même moi j'ai vu pompon boîter pendant
de
semaines je veux pas balancer mousse
hein
mais bon j'ai vu Duin dans la salle C
maintenant on arrive au
scoop du bouquin d'
lodiu regarde comment il se délct parce
que c'est comme hardardity c'est comme
hardardityti qui est balancé par serro
dans son bouquin mais cro dit pas que
c'est hardardityti là vous dites pas qui
c'est et c'est marrant tout le monde va
le reconnaître comme tout le monde a
reconnu hardardityti dans le bouquin de
serro un journaliste de renom dont je
Teré l'identité par charité tant son
attitude m'a choqué et déçue a également
tenté sa chance j'avais une certaine
admiration pour lui ne croyez pas ceux
qui mettaient en garde m'assurant que sa
moralité était inversement
proportionnelle à sa suffisance et qu'il
ne reculait pas devant des méthodes
journalistiques plus que douteuses pour
se faire mousser j'y voyais là pure
jalousie de la part de ces détracteurs
jusqu'au jour où j'ai
rencontré jusqu'au jour où j'ai
rencontré l'homme en question dans un
studio de télévision je dois reconnaître
qu'il est allé droit au but sans perdre
de temps côté efficacité rien à dire
nous nous connaissions depuis 1 heure à
peine qu'il me demandait déjà assez
familièrement tu as quelqu'un en ce
moment comme je suis une franchise
indécrotable toujours la ferme he j'ai
dis la vérité non je suis seul et alors
là j'ai droit à un numéro exceptionnel
qui me laisse boucheb une caricature de
drague à l'italienne à hurler de rire
oui tu es seul c'est normal à ton âge il
te faut quelqu'un qui t'apprenne
vraiment ce que c'est l'amour c'est ce
que tu attends ce dont tu as besoin je
vais m'en charger incroyable il ne me
demande même pas mon avis c'est tout
juste il n'ajoute pas et si on
commençait là tout de suite sur la
moquette enlève ta culotte pendant que
je me sers un whisky puis je commence
mal le son et tu oublieras pas de dire
merci monsieur tout le monde a compris
qui c'était
Jol bien donc si vous savez qui c'est
vous nous répondez sur le site France 2
et le 4 septembre nous vous donnerons la
réponse tout le monde a compris dis
juste qulè non non
[Musique]
non
et mes rêves mes passions mes espoirs
c'est publié chez Michel laond mesdames
[Musique]
messieurs j'accueille maintenant Nadia
far et Cécile
Gassel
mign toutes les deux là ou on va
travailler ça va ouis vous êtes toutes
les deux à la fiche de pour le plaisir
un film de Dominique de Ruder qui va
sortir le 14 juillet avec Samuel
lebillant François berléan Olivier
Gourmet Laurent Dutch et vous
deux vous voulez que je fasse le pitch
s'il vous plaît
alors l'histoire donc dans une petite
ville du nord François berléan qui est
garagiste va consulter Samuel lebillant
qui est psy voilà il dit ma femme c'est
vous sa femme me dit qu'elle ne peut
prendre du plaisir qu'avec des assassins
pas de crime pas
d'orgasme que dois-je faire docteur
alors le docteur lui répond entrer dans
son fantasme inventez-vous un crime VO
la méthe angroise voilà alors évidemment
au moment où le garagiste s'accuse d'un
meurtre auprès de sa femme un homme est
vraiment tué près de chez lui un mec
ignoble une brute épaisse et là berléan
devient une star ce qui est marrant dans
le film c'est que c'est l'assassin qui
devient une star puisqu'il a tué un
connard pourquoi tu me regardes comme ça
je trouve ça formidable elle a mis du
gloss tu es magnifique là je veux dire
ce soir tu as vraiment fait un effort
énorme merci parce que d'habitude c'est
pas terrible non mais là tu as fait un
effort excuse-moi Cécile tu as fait un
effort sur le gloss là ça se voit tout
de suite beaucoup je vais mettre des
fenêes noir
à un moment c'est beaucoup là ouis toi
aussi tu es très mignonne là c'est ça ça
te va mieux les cheveux de cette couleur
oui oui c pas difficile non mais l'autre
fois tu tu es venu tu étais un peu ouais
un peu queue de vache là là c'est joli
hein j'étais j'avais tout attaché voilà
mais j'aime bien ça j'aime bien ça bon
alors est celui qui a tué je parle de
berléan le garagiste son mécano Laurent
Dutch ou le psy le billan voilà mais
dites des trucs là vendez-le votre ah
oui c'est c'est aller le voir déjà le 14
juillet on fait une énorme fête feu
d'artifice pour la sortie un truc énorme
ça c'est déjà pas mal et puis et puis
ben je sais pas il y a pas une bande
annonce un truc qui qui donnerait envie
pour voir la bande annonce faut que tu
regardes ta caméra Nadia aussi c'est
laquelle c'est monur rouge vous dites
Magneto Serge attention à 3 1 2 3
Magneto Serge non non non non ça
marchera jamais ça il faut le dire en
même temps retard là pe 1 2 3 Magnetto
Serge ça peut
marcher dit que pour que ça fonctionne
il lui faut un tueur un mec qui a du
sonang sur les mains rentrez dans son
fantasme inventez-vous un crime ça y est
fait il avait des ennemis les gens qui
lui en voulaient ou il avait que des
ennemis il était temps que quelqu'un lui
donne une bonne leçon pour moi c'est
quelqu'un de bien qui a fait ça et qui
te dit que c'est pas moi on peut
toujours rêver ça essayer de tuer votre
mari ce
soirl avec l'assurance d'une totale
impunité 66 % des personnes interrogées
commettraent au moins un meurtre à
combien montrait ce pourcentage on leur
offrait la gloire c'est mon dossier
c'est votre
pressbook je crois que je suis tombé
amoureuse de vous d'après ce que vous
dites vous n'aimez que les assassins
[Musique]
justement y a bien quelqu'un qui a
tu vous faites payer cher pour
conseiller à vos clients de commettre un
meurtre voil pour le plaisir de
Dominique sorti le 14 juillet avec
Cécile Carel Nadia far Samuel lebillant
François berléan Laurent
[Musique]
Deutch c'est un film belge hein oui avec
un humour belge avec l'humour belge
complètement surréaliste complètement
insensé absurde comme le décrit le
réalisateur très très drôle et vous
Cécile vous êtes majorette dans le film
et vous êtes obligé de prendre des cours
de bâton exactement LAN de bâton oui oui
je travailler en France en Belgique
merci elles sont magnifiques toutes les
deux on dirait que vous allez dans une
soirée après on va une boom après ah ça
sent la fille qui s'est sapée tu sais un
peu mais c'est bien non mais c'est
vachement agréable he moi je TR aussiah
LOD tu as vu comment elle est bronzée
c'est un sensé non mais c'est du c'est
du
maquillage mais une fois tu es revenu
hyper hyper bronzé et je pensais que tu
t'étais mis un truc mais non non je
bronze très vite j'ai réglé ma télé
comme un
con bien alors les fill sa ce qu'on va
faire là ah non finiss son l'émission
d'abord
apr on va faire une interview déjà
[Musique]
dit est-ce que vous êtes déjà dit [__]
quel film de merde quand même
oui toi oui avec qui je les oublie ou
vouses déjà dit il est moche mais bon il
est
producteur non moi pas parce qu'à chaque
fois je su to tu es une sainte c'est ça
oui non non je suis pas une sainte non
j'ai pas mais j'ai toujours aimé
vraiment quand j'ai été avec un homme
j'ai je l'ai vraiment aimé je n'ai pas
connu de producteur donc je ne peux pas
vous êtes déjà dit tiens aujourd'hui je
joue vraiment comme une saucisse moi oui
surtout en voyant les films après
heureusement je me rends pas compte sur
le moment et toi Nadia non je me suis
plutôt dit j'aurais aimé être dirigé
peut-être d'une autre façon oua voilà
vous êtes déjà dit sérieusement avec une
fille c'est peut-être pas mal d'essayer
vu comme c'est compliqué avec vous je
vais peut-être m
mettre NAD non j'ai jamais essayé un
jour tu joues comme une saucisse tu peux
vous êtes déjà
dit
non 5 dans un lit c'est trop oui oui
carment le
chien vous êtes déjà dit allez h ma
grosse au
régime il y a de jours vousêes déjà dit
en voyant un mec lui c'est où il veut
quand il
veut
samedi soir non mon père
regarde mais en même temps bah oui bien
sûr mais ce serait dommage d'avoir
jamais pensé
çare c'est un nouveau truc c'est le B
c'est qu quelqu'unaconte des conneries
on le vous êtes déjà dit si ce film fait
pas un carton j'arrête le cinéma non
j'aurais
arrêté parce que j'ai fait que des
merdes vas-y je l' arrêé parce que j'ai
pas eu la chance de faire de de films
qui ont eu du succès mais celui-là va
tout changer bien sûr bon pour pas vous
êtes déjà l tous les mêmes finalement
non depuis que j'ai rencontré mon mari
non ah ouais ah tu l'aimes ce Steve là
et oui ouis qu'est-ce qu'il a plus que
les
autres ça m'intéresse qu'est-ce qu'il a
plus que les les autres cm tu veux c'est
quelqu'un qui
est c'est lodie qui m'a soufflé
s Nadia les 22 Maxime elle me fait c'est
non c'est quelqu'un avec qui on s'entend
bien je dirais sur tous les plans et
puis on partage beaucoup de choses
ensemble on se marre ensemble et voilà
et puis c'est quelqu'un qui sait être
doux et qui est profondément bon bah oui
bah oui bah oui voilà c'est et voilà
donc c'est c'est ça s'explique pas on
s'est vu la première fois ça a
été first side quoi ouais ça été un
regard et ça ça s'est fait voilà et ça
et ça continue et oui je sais sty et oui
c'était quoi comme genre de regard
c'était un petit regard de coquer voilà
qui m'a touché ah qu' a touche le regard
de coquire et toi c'est quoi qui te
touche ça ça marche pas non mais je sais
c'est un
ensemble CC C NAD
far pour le plaisir c'est un film très
marrant très très belle très
surréaliste les assassins sont des
stars tu vas aller au lit toi j'y
va au lit avec luiis rien va filmer
quand il va se reposer voilà
voilà dans tous les cas c'est demain à
15h30 sur France 5 les Falbala de
Jean-Paul gutier documentaire de Tony
Marchall merci
[Musique]
à
et
maintenant mon
[Musique]
petitou ma planche
blancheig fa bien
attention pasélo du Chem
de
[Musique]
Booba
bonsoir tu as les cheveux extrêmement
bien coupés non mais vraiment Jer ah ben
là je suis fasciné là vraiment ça te va
très très bien merci c'est gentil bien
alors Booba il rigole pas lui hein tu
rigoles pas toi si si ça va 20 27 ans
ouais deux albums certifiés disque d'or
deux passages en prison al on commence
par la prison comme ça ça sera fait donc
d'abord 4 ans pour avoir agressé deux
chauffeurs de taxi avec une arme à feu
ouais je mais liberté conditionnelle au
bout de 18 mois pourquoi parce que
j'étais sage ah tu vois ça marche alors
hein ouais bah c'était pas bien méchant
ils ont été un peu un peu dur avec moi
ouais ensuite 4 mois de préventif pour
tentative domicide volontaire là le
procureur réclamé 3 ans mais vous avez
été relaxé parce que par que j'étais
innocent ouais tu regrettes je regrette
de me te faire attraper surtout mais tu
dis que les gens qui sont en prison en
fait il y en a très peu qui regrettent
bah tant qu'on s'est pas fait attraper
je connais peu qui vont se rendre de
leur pleing gré quoi en se disant je
regrette ce que j'ai
fait logique voilà alors vous êtes
boobba métis Franco sénégalais né dans
les hautes scènes vers 101 ans quand vos
parents divorcent vous partez avec votre
mère à C surmer et é de vos 15 ans vous
allez aux USA et vous dites et là c'est
intéressant par rapport à ce que dit
payant dans je ne crois pas du tout à
l'intégration je préfère le système des
communautés à l'américaine donc vous
pensez que l'intégration républicaine à
la française c'est un modèle obsolète
ouais je pense que c'est hypocrite quoi
ouais on est mieux chez soi avec les
gens qui nous ressemblent c'est pas sans
être sectaire mais ouais aux États-Unis
voilà quoi ouais
quand il se rrou ils sont ensemble à
manattan par exemple il y a pas de
problème le soir ils se retrouvent chez
eux ils ont pas de tension ils sont dans
le communauté avec les gens qui on n
regarde pas de de haut en bas voilà
chacun chez soi et moi jefèire en tout
cas un modèle où on peut avoir des gens
qui sont divers et qui vivent ensemble
plutôt que d'être chacun dans son coin
et je pense quand même que ce modèle est
un modèle qui amène entre ces
communautés à des violences qui sont
extrêmement profondes et avec des
communautés qui sont quand même beaucoup
plus en
d'autes bon donc ça me semble pas un
modèle très souhaitable je pense qu'on
avait réussi à faire ensemble c'est
difficile à faire bon alors qu'on disent
moi je préfère être avec ceux qui sont
comme moi et cetera on le comprend tous
parce qu'on a tous un peu ça mais de là
à dire sans les autres c'est difficile
mais j'ai fait une interview l'année
dernière à la prison Florine mirogis et
je leur expliquais que éventuel enfin je
leur posais la question à savoir là
d'être en prison maintenant ici est-ce
que ça leur permettait eux d'avoir une
remise en question sur eux-même et
éventuellement d'évoluer de voir et les
gammes disaient non parce que en fait on
nous replonge comme ils les mettent par
par ces secteurs c'est ça mett en
communauté en prison gars des noir
clandestiné en fait communauté on nous
replonge dedans si si effectivement on
nous mettait un petit peu là là là là là
on serait pas en fait on se retrouve
tous les mêmes qui étaient dans les
cités à faire des des conneries se
retrouent pareil donc ils peuvent pas
évoluer il y a pas de il y a pas vrai
travail et un suivi pour essayer
justement de le de leur ouvrir d'autres
horizons quoi pour pour pour vous
l'avenir est au communautarisme en fait
vous vous pensez que l'intégration
républicaine c'est un modèle dépassé bah
je pense en tout cas ici ça marche pas
apparemment ouais ah ça marche pas parce
que vous dites vous par exemple quand il
fallait me réinscrire au
collège ma mère me disait te montre pas
comme ça ma mère elle elle est blanche
ça passe mieux
ouais par exemple vous dites en France
même avec une belle voiture tu te fais
contrôler deux fois par jour il il y a
toujours vous dites ce plafond qu'on
narrive pas à percer quoi il y a quels
que soient les moyens dont on dispose
quand on est noir on sera toujours un
sous-citoyen c'est ce que vous dites en
fait
ouis je pense ouis noir ou arabe h
pensez que c'est sans espoir Mo j'ai pas
trop d'espoir à ce niveau-là
h tu vois c'est quand même et si dit ça
enfin moi ce que j'entends c'est qu'en
même temps il y a quand même une forme
de regret parce que je vois pas pourquoi
il serait pas un citoyen comme les
autres donc ça condamne pas le modè
républicain ça dit il marche mal ça
c'est évident qu'il marche mal mais ou
qui marche pas à mon avis ça marche
mieux quand même que là où il y a pas
mais il a des ratés terribles il a des
ratés depuis 20 ans considérables et
d'ailleurs on voit les brisures moi ça
me donne plutôt le sentiment qu'il
faudrait que ça marche mieux plutôt que
dire ce modèle bien sûr on pense tous ça
voilà mais il y a des gens qui croient
plus du tout ça j'ai bien compris c'est
inquiétant vous dites je raconte la dure
réalité le mal de vivre si on mettait
mes textes en imag ce serait sûrement
interdit au moins de 16
ans fait des textes extrêmement violents
il y a même dans votre CD il y a un
texte dans votre CD qui est bâtiment C
qui même pas reproduit sur le livret
tellement il est violent
c'est pour éviter les ennuis avec la
justice surtout moi il me dérange pas ce
texteou il est violent mais bon pour moi
c'est normal c'est la réalité alors
votre nouvel album qui est le deuxème
album solo que vous faites Booba
s'appelle Panthéon c'est chez
barclley vous pensez que cette musique
ce genre de texte devrait avoir sa place
au pant on pas forcément c'est plus un
symbole c'est histoire de dire qu'on
essaie de faire de grandes choses quoi
ouais vos chansons racontent les
gonzesses les flings les flics les
bandes les cités la cam et la la plus
sympa de toutes c'est numéro 10 c'est la
plus optimiste pas ça tombe du ciel c
pas numéro 10 à Paname tu la banane du
siècle là où je nombre les Vic des
numéros Mar de l' je me et j'obser
imprime sur le r là où nbre les victimes
numéros 10 dans Mar Orlando exige le
clip du ciel si pas numéro 10 à Paname
tu es la banane du siècle là où j'ère
nombre les victimes que des numéros 10
marche que N per je me ser et j'observe
imprime nos rimes sur le ring au buld là
où nombreux sont les victimes des
numéros 10 dans mar r CR produit je su
chur livreur beaucoup de fleurs à mon
enterrement entouré de chiffreur n on
plaisante pas avec
[Musique]
le ah oui ça c'est le plus sympa de tous
numéro
jeun on vous compare à Céline et c'est
vrai que finalement on pourrait dire que
jeuner Céline c'était des rappeurs sans
musique personnellement moi je les ai
pas lu je connais pas du tout ce qu'il
font je sais que c'est des grands
écrivains mais j'en sais pas plus
connais pas rou
pas
chans alors vous êtes le 25 août à ber
avec cent en première partie c'est
bien vous sourirez jamais qu'est-ce qui
pourrait vous faire plaisir car de je m
branle de tes questions à la
con l'album s'appelle
[Musique]
pantéon vcent je vais t'envoyer de
coucher merci d'
nous P merci à
bientôt
et
[Musique]
maintenant voici Nicolas
Louis
comment ça va ça va bien très bien donc
la dernière fois que tu es venu on avait
eu Louis laner par RRO aujourd'hui il
vient vraiment pour la sortie de son
livre qui s'appelle un pur roman c'est
publié évidemment au diable V ver comme
tout ce que vous faites tous les deux
vous êtes au diable V ver voilà le pit
Louis bah c'est l'histoire de Virgil qui
a 26 ans et qui comme beaucoup de gens
rêvent de faire de la télé et et donc il
s'imagine que le dernier univers rock
and roll dans lequel il va pouvoir
s'amuser c'est justement la télé il
pense qu'il va pouvoir sortir avec des
filles plus belles que qu'ailleurs qui
va pouvoir faire des choses
extraordinaires comme peut-être partir
en weekend avec avec Séverine Ferrer
enfin bon des choses comme ça assez
magiques dans ce livre il est là il veut
devenir une star il est pas le seul on
veut tous devenir des stars maintenant
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui je suis
très content d'être enfin invité
officiellement j'ai pu venir sans sans
sans sans sans taper le vigile à
l'entrée il y avait même une demi loge
pour moi voilà un verre de champagne
donc c'est magique ça va Louis ça va ça
d'accord je je vais dire un extrait d'un
pur roman ça va bien énerver Booba à mon
avis comme tous les enfants riches je
suis beau les papas riches épouse de
belles mamans je suis l'ultime
aboutissement de cette sélection par
l'argent comme tous les beaux enfants je
seraai bientôt une star j'ai du temps
pour ça je n'ai pas besoin de dépenser
mon énergie à gagner ma vie ma vie est
déjà gagnée j'ai une [__] de longueur
d'avance sur vous pendant que vous serez
bloqué dans la queue du casting de la
Star Academy 6 j'aurais déjà écrit le
scénario de la star 7 la vie est injuste
je suis la preuve vivante que notre pays
n'est pas une république que les hommes
ne naissent pas égaux en droit et ne
demeure encore moins je ne suis pas
votre égal mais si vous pouviez croire
en cette égalité révolutionnaire ça
m'arrangerait bien pensez que tout le
monde peut être star suivre les conseils
démocratiques des profs qui vous demande
de rester vous-même surtout restez
vous-même ne changez rien vous êtes
parfait ça manque un peu de cynisme mais
c'est pas mal c'est ce qu'on appelle la
littérature tu à claque tu sais c'est
mais c'est pas mal là tu te démerdes
Louis en même temps c'est toi qui l'a
écrit c'est très provocquant Louis oui
en fait moi je n'ai rien à voir avec ce
héros en fait moi j'ai j'ai j'ai je suis
un garçon très tendre j'ai eu une
histoire d'amour un petit peu compliquée
avec une fille qui s'appelle Céline et
qui me regardera pas ce soir et c'est
une fille pas mal si je peux faire rêver
un petit peu les gens qu'est-ce que je
peux dire elle a 25 ans bon ça déjà ça
fait rêver je pense ensuite elle a un
tatouage de salamande sur la hanche
droite elle a une peau couleur sucrée
mais vraiment sucre de canne un petit
peu un petit peu comme toi et le dit et
et c'est vrai que c'est vrai que pour
moi c'est difficile et car de ferme un
peu ta
gueule non c'est pas mal écrit hein
c'est très très bien c'est bien écrit
ouais c'est euh c'est bien écrit mais
c'est énervant mais oui mais comme
toutes les choses un peu comme ça qui
sont comme ça à ce point réussi si les
montipyon avaiit fait l'amour avec des
proches ça auraiit donné Louis laner
mais bon ça pas été le cas et et et en
plus il y a un plaisir de lecture
immédiat évident c'est la phrase de
toyoy on oublie qu'on lit vraiment et
moi j'ai eu je l'ai même fini alors que
ton Pr je l'avais pas son premier livre
je l'avais moins fini et celui-ci je
l'ai non non je je l'ai fini je l'ai
trouvé formidable c'est pas le voyage au
bout de la nuit non plus mais mais pour
l'été c'est excellent comme on arrive
quasiment en été c'est l'antioua d'une
certaine façon hein c'est vrai je suis
pas le bad boy de la littérature on peut
pas dire ça bon c'est en même temps il
est très sauvage
parfois je m'en suis rendu compte alors
votre prochain livre vous dites vous
allez changer complètement de style vous
allez décrire une enfance asthmatique
j'avais pas de papa et tout vous allez
faire ple un peu bah peut-être peut-être
que finalement peut-être que ça pourrait
mieux fonctionner non notre prochain
livre je crois qu'on va peut-être écrire
un Nicolas qu'est-ce que tu en penses je
t'en parle maintenant là parce qu'on sur
Elodie mais j'y pense aussi livre à un
livre à qu mains onire on regardait la
ferme tous les soirs avec Louis ah luoui
s connaî en
téléréalité nous on avait une c'est vrai
une vision des des Miss France un peu
comme ça impeccable au pH neutre et tout
et vous il y avait quelque chose d'un
peu d'un peu sale et joli à regarder
comme si vous sentiez la ur et ça
c'était beau 2004 bravo non non c'est
vrai c'est vrai Louis LAN vous êtes un
petit peu sur les traces de de Frédéric
BBD de de Nicolas Reay enfin cette cette
nouvelle littérature qu'on peut appeler
un peu la littérature tête à claque donc
hein tu a des jeunes gens riches et beau
qu' le proclame et ça énerve les autres
ouais mais c'est parce que moi j'avais
une mère prof de français prof de philo
un grand-père prof de patoilorin donc
j'essaie de me projeter là-dedans de
t'en sortir j'essa mais je sais pas
entre b b Nicol vous préférez qui
euh souvent on associe nicolar BBD et je
je c'est étrange parce que je trouve que
c'est pas du tout la même littérature en
on va voir on va faire une interview
Nicol contre BBD et c'est vous qui
répondez Louis celui qui couche avec les
plus jolies filles c'est nicolear ou
frééric
bebéd je connais moins je connais moins
celle celle de frééric B toi c'est V que
tu es assez sage ces derniers temps on
peut le dire celui qui écrit les
meilleurs livres c'est frérib ou
Nicolas fais gaffe lou c'est ta carrière
qui se joue ce so lequel est le plus
important est-ce que c'est mieux de se
fâcher avec Nicola ou avec BBD je sais
pas très bien que tu veux ce que je
veux je crois que Nicolas est en train
de monter en puissance et c'est pas
pareil peut-être que Nicolas a plus de
facilité et il a du mal et et plus plus
là c'est terrible pour lui hein c'est
celui qui tient le mieux l'alcool dans
les soirées c'est nicolar ou Frédéric
bebd il y a eu il y a eu quelques
soirées qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on
sétait fait comme soirée alcoolisée il y
avait eu la soirée champemis c'était
très bien ça c'était bien on a fait une
soirée tisane également et Frédéric
était torché en fait on l'avait
vu pas du tout celui qui est le plus à
l'aise devant une caméra c'est Nicolas
ou Frédéric bebéd c'est certainement pas
moi je crois qu'on l'aura compris
euh suicide-toi suicide-toi tu as pas de
de choix c'est horrible suicide-toi
c'est ce soir ce soir est-ce que est-ce
que je peux peut-être vous rappeler
faire un vote par par sms je tap un si
je vote Frédéric de si je vote Nicolas
non c'est pas possible plus à l'aise
plus à
l'aise dans l'hyerch Ctait Frédérique
ouais je c voilà c'est ça celui qui
finira grand écrivain c'est be BD ou
Nicol Ry quel [__] ah c'est c'est
horrible hein ça je reconnais mais il y
a il y a toujours le public estention le
public le public se dit c'est horrible
de voir un jeune écrivain assez
talentueux se chier dessus en
direct
celui qui finira par une overdose dans
les toilettes du VIP c'est fr big BB ou
c'est
Nicolas euh dépend une overdose de quoi
on avait parlé tout à l'heure de la
tisane qu'est-ce qu'il y avait eu comme
il y avait eu des overdoses Frédéric
aime bien les bonbons c'est vrai faut
qu'il fasse attention il peut grossir il
est un peu gros celui qui est moins
insupportable qu'il en a l'air c'est bec
BD ou nicolar euh nicolar est encore
plus gentil qu'il en a l'air il a jamais
tu as jamais l'air insupportable c'est
vrai qu' un gros melon un gros melon
euh
c'est mal c'est horrible non mais je
sais ce que je te fais là c'est terrible
je sais quand j'étais petit j'arrachais
les ailes des mouches ouais tu me
compares à une mouche c'est ça non j'ai
l'impression de faire çapr tu faisais
quoi la mouche après la mouche fou tu l'
laissé tu l'enculais pas
non
dommage celui qui vous énerverait le
plus si vous le connaissiez pas c'est
Nicolas ou fré
bbé mais je je ne les connais tous les
deux qu'après 22h je pense que je les
connais pas vraiment en fait donc je
pense que bb a une bonne faculté
énervant voilà le plus superficiel des
deux c'est
lequel vous savez moi j'emplo très peu
de motif tu veux t'ouvrir les venes tout
de
suite du matos on pe pe s'arranger on
peut avoir une lame de rasoir s'il te
plaît celui qui est le plus opportuniste
des deux c'est Nicolas ou Frédéric bbé
bah par bbéd on l'a vu dès qu'il a
l'occasion de faire une grande émission
de télé il l'a faite d'ailleurs j avais
participé et et ça a très bien marché
donc je pense que les deux sont des
grand écout on va donner une occasion de
répondre là celui qui a la plus grosse
[__] c'est Frédéric B ou
Nicolas mais il y a pas sa [__] sur la
4e de GO non il pas si il y a une [__]
de diable par contre on a une grosse
[__] de diable c'est du DI vert oui
vas-y alors c'est des fores différentes
il y en a un c'est plus une berline et
l'autre c'est plus un coupé sport
maintenant ce qu'il faut que je rend
dans les
détailsou tu es le dernier invité de la
saison en même temps tu payes pour les
autres
un pur roman Louis LAN au
diable Nicol courir à 30
ans on passe au blind
test et pour ce dernier blind test nous
allons tester une nouvelle formule la
battle donc il faut
et j'accue a leup et CR de
multifonction bonsoir bonsoir Chris
bonsoir exel donc pendant la première
partie c'està-dire le par équipe vous
enverrez un titre chacun et au moment
des banc vous enverrez chacun vos titres
en même temps ce qui sera encore plus
difficileid
alors il a dear ce soir avec nous il y a
jeandouard Lipa et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Pascal qu'est-ce que tu fais jeanard là
on vient de commencer une nouvelle pièce
à la Comédie de Paris qui s'appelle le
talon d'achile qui se joue tous les
soirs à 21h30 avec Daniel Jean coloredo
frédri Marion dum et
douel la coméie de Paris le tal d'ACh la
Comédie de Paris
tuis prépare un deè DVD ah
que des inédit que des iné 100% bien
bien tu es prêt à les aider oui AX vas-y
[Musique]
l'interprète
les
non coucher ta mais qu'est-ce que c'est
enfin al c'est aussi
connu mais c'est qui Remo un petit bout
a personne sait oh là là
attention e rider
non bon donc c'est zé partout c'est
steepen Wolf
[Musique]
révélation Z0 partout match nul pour le
moment à toi
[Musique]
Chris
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Mel Bros
bravo un point pour l'équipe de Pascal
selem he voilà et Z0 pour toi Laurent
parce que la vie est injuste non c'est
pas encore là c'est pas maintenant c'est
après il faut y penser hein attention
Axel Jager RollingStone
[Applaudissements]
rollingst bien donc là on est à deux
pour l'équipe de Pascal C à zé pouro
parce que la vie est injuste non c'est
pas
maintenant attention Chris bonjour
[Musique]
etou con
con non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouour à
to lour non lour non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
suivant
[Musique]
oui oui oui oui oui
oui
c'est c'est une chanson reprise par bien
entendu reprise par qui est sur la bande
la bande du dernier Tarantino mais là
c'est par
bravo on en est où M ça fait de points
pour l'équipe de Laurent baffi 3 points
pour l'équipe de
pascalem on continue à
toi
[Musique]
2 4 attention à
toiation c'est bien pour une fille de
l'UMP vraim je non inscrit non inscrit
alle tu as pas osé quand même ouis j'ai
pas osé bien Axel il dor ouais oh là là
ouis bravo
Yan petit
jou on comprend pourquoi l'illustration
musicale de ton film est tellement bonne
tu t'y connais à
toi voulez-vous
marmel
chante la
ouz
avecz
avec qu'est-ce qui se passe Pascal ils
sont un petit peu au taquet à côté là on
monte en puissance il monte en puissance
c'est des littéraires en même temps do
tout leur demander non plus
attention c'est à toi
Boua il est s il est sû
[Musique]
Boua la
musi 5
5 il est fort Bou 55 ouais
attention c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention AC
non non on ne souffle pas non on ne
souffle
pas on ne souffle
[Musique]
pas mais venez
ici
[Musique]
bravo
donc c'est vous qui marquez le point
puisque la personne qui a trouvé de ce
côté voilà bravo merci on vous fera
l'amour madame àâ d'avoir écouté
l'original quand c'est sorti comme moi
voilà très bien on continue c'est très
très dur maintenant c'est à toi kitar
[Musique]
ouais
comment il va frimer ce soir à la maison
on continue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Axel ah
ouais alors à l'issue du par équipe on
est à 77
voilà alors là je vais être obligé
d'envoyer un morceau et puis pour faire
choisir les gens voilà parce queil faut
ah j'ai ça attention dites-moi qui
[Musique]
c'est
voilà c'est donc l'équipe de bascal C
qui l' en pense Laurent al voilà c'est
torché malgré boa qui a bien aidé heinou
il a bien aidé il a bien aidé Booba
ouisou beaucoup de figurations je do
dire mais bon c'est alors maintenant
c'est très compliqué parce qu'on arrive
donc au chacun pour sa
gueule chacun pour sa gueule je sais pas
on a jamais répété ça voilà pourquoi
pourquoi parce que la vie est injuste
et voilà et vous le savez maintenant
alors donc là vous allez jouer chacun
les morceaux en même temps évidemment ça
va être extrêmement compliqué de c'est
la battle c'est Le Bastard mix attention
à
[Musique]
vous il y a les
Clash
bravo ou
bravo
[Musique]
voilà cétait l'éclat
chez on passe au
suivant on passe au suivant attention à
[Musique]
vous du
tropche non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
ta fille
et Pascal et Laurent voilà évidemment
Pascal et Laurent toujours les mêmes
voilà attention l'ultra banco c'est
extrêmement compliqué ce sont deux
chanteuses et vous les jouz en même
temps à
[Musique]
vous
ou
bravo
comment tu as fait mais effectivement C
mais tu as trouvé les deux tu as trouvé
j J et Paul Abdou gagné le blind test
c'était l'ultra banco et le dernier
blindest de l'anné ou a gagné
C
bra mais je remet coici quand même bravo
CC c c qui rorte tu as trouvé les deux
en
plus c'est bien Janny Joplin Paul Abdou
c'est formidable comment tu as fait
Janice Joplin c'est une de mes
chanteuses préférées et Paul Abdou
comment pauld personne trouvé je sais
pas après avoir on a dit plein de trucs
et puis ça sonnait un peu 90 80 voilà
Paul Abdou pouro c'est bien respect
vraiment merci à tous merci à Laurent
MAFF
merci merci à
Michel les pied chez
édition PARAD
ireier 21 juillet etalum de PARAD
[Musique]
avecamain 7
juilletandiginamain
[Musique]
JUET age voilà vcent payant les
milliards noirs du blanchiment chez HC
littérature Jean-Paul Gautier et Tony
Marchall les falbalad de Jean-Paul
Gautier de Tony Marchall dimanche demain
à 15h30 sur Arté voilà Jean-Paul Gautier
l'exposition pas couture par Jean-Paul
Gautier jusqu'au 10 octobre à la
Fondation quartier pour l'art
contemporain Ivan Atal il se marièrent
et eurent beaucoup d'enfants de Ivan
hatal avec Ivan hatal Charlotte gbourg
Anou al chaba Emmanuel seier et Johnny
deppp ça sort le 25 août voilà et
leodin mes rêves mes passions mes
espoirs c'est chez Michel Laffond Nadia
Faret Cécile Cassel pour le plaisir de
Dominique duder avec Nadia Ccile Cass
Samuel lebillant et Laurent Deutch sorti
le 14 juillet voilà Booba l'album
s'appelle Panthéon et il sera le 25 aût
à Bercy avec F C en première partie et
le 25 septembre à Bercy voilà Boua Louis
laner un pur roman c'est publié au
diable VAT nicolasay courir à 30 ans
publié également au diable B vert voilà
c'était tout le monde en parle
rendez-vous à la rentrée et d'ici là
opinion publique lundi à 20h50 c'est sur
France 2
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci
[Musique]
je suis le génie de la
bouche cetteou magique va te transporter
dans une
dimension
parallèle pou
[Musique]
dans
1 2 3 je film bouche je claque des
doigts 4 5 6 c'est plus facile pour sur
la piste 7 8 9 dans cette super te il y
a trop ple 9 10 11 12 je chercher je
trouve pas de r jette des baskets en
l'air les T tennis on a rien à
faireouche c'est l'heure de mettre une
petite touche de ch mais dans
[Musique]
ton
b
[Musique]
ok
Laou laille en rougeut que tu bouges le
garçon en Bleis ce que tu
[Musique]
veux et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de tube abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu